Optimal at this altitude.
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
No one else will be posting a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue over another.
This episode is brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast and readers in mind love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices,
track your time and get paid very,
very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot of freelancers,
a lot of Ottawa plunderers and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit card and debit card,
so all of the things you buy automatically appear in your fresh books in the
right category,
so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy,
makes invoices easy.
It makes your life easier.
And also in fact,
I would recommend a pdf.
They didn't ask me to read this part by the way.
They'd put the other pdf a while back called breaking the time barrier subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with a service business and the story in
that Ebook,
it's pdf is the short answer is really,
really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
check it out,
but also why not test out freshbooks.
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
Inter Tim Ferriss,
two r's and two s's in the how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very little tracking and it's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and try it out because it is a
very good product and I think you will find it simplifies your life.
Enjoy.
Yeah.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
I absolutely love audio books in there.
One of my favorite ways to pass the time when I travel,
I'm on the road all the time in audible allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have to audio books to recommend right off the
bat.
The first is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time and it's the only
audiobook I've wanted to listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
p,
o t t,
s which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what
would later become the four hour workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim and you can choose one of these two books
or any many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines and much more as a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash.
Tim,
you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it.
So turn your travel or your commute into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start now and get your free 30 day trial.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is always my job to tease out the habits,
routines,
philosophies,
favorite books,
et Cetera,
from world class performers so you can test each of those in your own life.
And guests range from say those in business,
sports,
military,
all the way to the esoteric and sometimes a very unexpected.
And this guest checks a lot of boxes.
His name is Nick Savo,
that's s.
Z.
A.
B.
O.
Many of you may not recognize his name,
but hopefully by the end you'll want to know everything that he puts out and
read.
Every essay that he puts on the Internet.
He is a polymath.
The breadth and depth of his interests and knowledge are truly astounding and I
mean jaw dropping.
It's,
it's just beyond belief what this guy can cover.
He's a computer scientist,
legal scholar and cryptographer best known for his pioneering research in
digital contracts and crypto currency and I've long been fascinated by crypto
currency but secretly not really understood anything about it or certainly the
subtleties and this episode is really a masterclass so we go from the very,
very basic all the way up to the cutting edge and what the future holds.
Nick,
for instance,
developed the phrase and concept of smart contracts with the goal of bringing
what he calls the highly evolved practices of contract long practice to the
design of all electronic commerce protocols between strangers on the Internet.
Nick also designed bit gold,
which many consider the precursor to bitcoin.
This particular conversation is co hosted by one of my favorite people,
naval Ravikant,
a mutual friend and one of the most successful investors in silicon valley who
also happens to be one of Nick's biggest admirers and a for those who enjoy it.
And of all here.
You may also enjoy his first episode with me from 2015 which was voted on
product hunt,
the second best podcast episode of the year across all podcasts with the
exception of my Jamie Foxx episode,
so you can listen to that if you'd like.
It's called the evolutionary angel episode,
Tim.
Dot.
Blog forward slash,
Nepal,
but let's get back to how much we cover with nick because it's a lot and you
need not be intimidated.
You don't need to be a computer scientist.
I am not.
You don't need to know anything about currency.
I know very little,
but we get into the history of money.
We talk about Bitcoin,
what it is,
what cryptocurrencies are and what problems they solve.
We define social scalability.
What is that and why is it important?
What is a theory of what makes it unique?
Strengths and weaknesses.
We talked about different types of cryptocurrencies.
We talk about things calling for instance,
altcoin.
What the hell is that?
We get into it.
What are icls initial coin offerings we talked about who might invest or not
invest in?
Certainly this is not investment advice.
It's for informational purposes only.
So talk to your financial professional before allocating resources or money
anywhere.
Okay,
cover my ass.
Good.
How will smart contracts actually get adopted to go mainstream?
Right?
If you think of,
say bitcoin is something that is very fringe,
when will it hit the tipping point?
What might the elements be that would lead to that blockchain governance?
Is there any existential risk?
Could governments or regulators shut down something like bitcoin?
What is what code versus dry code?
This is a super,
super cool distinction that I really enjoyed.
What are Pascal's scams or quantum thought?
We dig into all sorts of nooks and crannies including what's nick might work on
in the future,
what fields does he want to explore and so on.
So this was to me a really,
really fun and mind expanding conversation.
You do not need to be technical or an engineer to enjoy it and get a lot out of
it.
Because at the core we are really looking at how to people who are very,
very smart,
meaning nick and Laval process the world,
what lenses they use to view the world and how that dictates their actions and
how they get better results.
So if you want more from nick,
and we'll talk about this at the very end of the conversation also,
but you have to check out the essays on his blog,
which is called [inaudible] numerated,
it's on a numerated.blogspot.com but that can wait for later.
And then you will know why many of the thought leaders in Silicon Valley and
around the world really pay a lot of attention to neck.
So without further ado,
please enjoy this wide ranging conversation with Nick Sabo.
All Right,
gentlemen,
I think the hour has arrived.
[inaudible] welcome back.
Thank you.
It's good to be back.
Once again.
Nick.
Pleasure to meet you.
Nice to me.
And I'm very excited and also intimidated by the conversation we're about to
have as context for people listening.
We're going to delve into some subjects I have an acute interest in,
but,
uh,
extreme ignorance of,
so I will let them all do a lot of the driving and,
uh,
I figured to place we could start is at the beginning at least where you guys
met.
So how did you two first connect?
Yeah,
like most of my close relationships these days,
I formed them on Twitter
and a,
I think go Twitter as the place where I go to,
to have a great conversation when I can't have one locally,
which seems to be all the time.
And the more time
that I spend on Twitter,
the more I sort of curate this incredible group of very intelligent people that
I just get to know purely through the quality of their thoughts.
Um,
and so I think,
uh,
when I was getting into cryptocurrencies and blockchains,
doing my homework on it,
I stumbled across a blog called an enumerated.
Um,
and maybe nick can go into what the origins of that word are,
but,
uh,
it was obviously written by a polymath,
someone who wrote about everything.
I got into the blog and then I started following the author,
which was nick on Twitter,
retweet it,
or as few as tweets and got into little bite size,
160 character conversations.
And here we are.
How has that relationship developed?
In other words,
how are we here today?
And you could take a stab at that.
Yeah,
Nick's going to do plenty of targets and we certainly have him chime in,
but if you want to,
if you want to lead us to how we ended up here today.
Yeah.
I mean,
it was just more and more tweeting back and forth reading next articles.
Uh,
there's one that he put up recently around social scalability,
which I thought was literally mind blowing.
Like I thought I knew a lot about cryptocurrencies,
but it really just helped me reframe what I knew in a better mental model.
Uh,
you know how Charlie Munger talks about mental models?
So I've actually picked up at least four or five mental models from neck,
which I think is more than I may have from any human being other than Charlie
monger.
I was tweeting out sections of that article.
Then somebody said,
well,
nick and Novalis should do a podcast,
and I was like,
well,
they didn't never do a podcast with me.
And then Nick said,
sure,
I'll do a podcast.
So here we are.
Nick,
could you maybe help us with some definitions?
So cryptocurrency,
there are a number of other words,
they're going to come up a lot and these are words that I feel at many dinner
parties and say Silicon Valley people will not ask about because they're afraid.
They're the only ones at the table who don't actually know how to define it.
But since I can't play the part of knowing what I don't know in this case,
what is cryptocurrency and how did you become interested in it or start thinking
about it?
Cryptocurrency as the name suggests,
is protected by cryptography.
And in particular the modern crypto currency like bitcoin and ethereum,
so forth are protected by their integrity,
is protected by cryptography.
A,
a structure called a Merkle tree that you can think of it as a a fly getting
trapped in amber.
You,
if you say,
I shot JFK and then put it through this process of the Merkle tree,
putting it on the blockchain,
then it's there.
You can't,
and you've signed it with your,
with your private key,
then you can't later deny,
oh,
I shot,
didn't say that.
That allows you to like make a statement,
you know,
I'm paying such and such amount of Bitcoin to somebody else and then put it
there after a few cycles called block times,
which should take about 10 minutes each.
Um,
it gets exponentially more difficult to deny or take back that,
that this transaction took place.
How did you first begin thinking about this,
these,
these types of,
or any of this really,
where did the interest to begin?
Well,
we had a group called the cypherpunks back in the 1990s.
Um,
Tim May and Eric Hughes and John Gilmore and so forth.
And uh,
Tim may had,
so partly this is political that Tim may had a,
a vision of Gulf sculpture in cyberspace of any of your audience or ion ran
fans.
They'll recognize the reference to galt sculptures is places you can go to get
away from things into your business,
um,
without outside interference in,
in the book.
That was like a physics fantasy.
But Tim goes,
well,
we have strong cryptography now so we can do that.
And I thought,
well,
yes,
but you still want to do things like,
um,
enforce contracts and protect property and so forth.
So I,
and I started thinking about,
um,
and to some extent some other people started thinking about how to apply
computer science to,
um,
to protect Your Business in cyberspace.
This bleeds into,
I did just enough reading to hopefully have questions to ask.
I didn't want to read so much that I left out basics fundamentals for people.
It's cryptography.
If it,
most people think that they hear that word,
maybe exposure they've had is watching a movie that involves an enigma machine
or something like that.
But what is cryptography?
The original cryptography is,
is if you saw that movie is keeping secrets in this case,
in that movie,
the Nazis failing to keep secrets from the British and Alan Turing cause there
are cryptography wasn't strong enough,
but these days you have really strong cryptography.
So breaking it in that brute force men are like,
um,
they broke the Nazi codes is pretty unlikely these days.
Um,
there are some other things you can do like take people's private keys and so
forth,
but the PR,
the brute force attack doesn't work anymore.
I mean there are some old cyphers where we're,
we're starting to work,
but um,
as long as you have the latest stuff like bitcoin does,
then,
then you're fine.
Yeah,
I would say it's like basically keeping secrets through mathematics and,
uh,
there are many,
many breakthroughs that enabled cryptocurrencies.
But,
uh,
one of the key things to understand cryptography is this concept of one way,
encoding one way hash functions.
Basically,
I can take some data,
run it through a mathematical transformation.
And what comes out of the other side is really hard to undo.
It's really hard to work backwards.
So it's kind of a one way thing
is when people send encrypted email through say PGP or something like that.
Is that an example?
Yeah.
Basically what I've done,
so in the old days,
if I was encrypting something,
we would both have the same key,
right?
And so,
or I would have a key that I would take your key,
I would encrypt with your key,
sent it to you.
You have the key you can decrypt with a key.
But the problem was how do I figure out what your key is,
how to figure out how to encrypt it and because your key can both encrypt and
decrypt.
So if I had a hold of your key,
then I could open the message,
right?
So it's very unsafe to transmit that key.
And so one of the innovations that came along with this idea of splitting the
key into a public key and a private key.
So a private keys,
what you hold on that can decrypt and encrypt stuff,
your public key on the other hand,
other people can encrypt to it for you,
but they can't use it.
It's a right on it.
Yeah,
it's a one way kind of thing.
So I mean this is probably beyond the scope of this discussion,
but it's worth digging a little bit into what are called one way hash functions
and public keys and private keys.
Cause they underlie a lot of cryptography and they seem like complicated
concepts,
but they're not that complicated.
Uh,
and I,
I would argue this is one of those mental models that you kind of have to figure
out tot start operating the modern technological world.
Um,
but cryptocurrencies essentially use these one way hash functions to make
statements like I gave Tim $10,
right?
So if I said I gave you $10,
normally we need a central authority to verify that the bank has to verify that.
And the central bank has diversified.
Well this leads to the question of,
and I'm not going to interrupt beyond this,
but why,
why create cryptocurrency?
Why is it important?
What are the benefits?
Yeah,
so I mean,
one huge benefit is we don't need any more,
a trusted third party to verify that transaction.
We can do it in the cloud through a distributed network,
which is kind of what the cryptocurrency does.
Um,
but I'll,
I'll let nick talk more about this,
but he had a great quote,
um,
that I think is very irrelevant where he said,
uh,
this is the dawn of trustworthy computing,
right?
Because before this computer to kind of untrusted,
like if I send you money from my computer to your computer,
we're really relying on visa and the banks and a bunch of intermediaries just
actually say,
yes,
the money got to you and the money's no longer mine.
Uh,
but computers don't like to operate like that.
Computers,
you know,
Computer Code,
especially,
uh,
stuff that's running in the cloud on it's own,
shouldn't have to rely on an offline wet space meetspace institution to enforce
that kind of thing.
Um,
so cryptocurrencies take the concept of money and they take it native into
computers where everything is settled with computers and doesn't require
external institutions are trusted third parties to validate things.
Just to try to paraphrase that for my own understanding.
So in other words,
you don't have to say trust a stranger to do something.
You don't have to trust a central authority to be the arbiter of whatever
decisions end up being made are implemented.
It's built into the technology itself.
Yeah.
Why?
Why is cryptocurrency important to you?
So it's important for,
I think,
the,
the partially political reason to gain more independence,
um,
of your life from these institutions.
And it just creates a new capabilities.
Like somebody now in Guatemala can base somebody in Canada without using an
intermediary New York City or something that's just greatly advantageous for
global commerce,
I think.
Yeah.
So if I can just dig into that a little bit more,
definitely dig in.
I also at some point,
because this word is plagued me for a few years now,
blockchain,
I do not know what it means and I don't why it's called blockchain.
I actually thought Nick's,
uh,
earlier analogy of a fly getting trapped in amber is kind of brilliant.
Um,
like if you see a fly in amber and it's got,
you know,
a millimeter of amber around it,
well that could have been done yesterday or you know,
like a year ago.
But if you see the fly is trapped in a huge block of amber,
you know,
it's been there for a long,
long time.
It's been accumulating.
So a blockchain is a series of blocks.
Each block is a series of computations done by computers all over the world
using serious cryptography in a way that's very hard to undo.
So each block is like another thin layer of amber.
I see.
And the chain of blocks represents the depth of that amber,
how long that fly has been trapped in and therefore how you can trust that
honest signal.
Anything deep down in the blockchain is mathematically cryptographically and
just economically impossible to undo.
Got It.
Okay.
Actually I shouldn't,
you use words like impossible and cryptography is all that it was always him.
Probable,
probable,
yeah.
What are some other core concepts that people should understand just as the
cryptocurrency one o one or currency one on one.
I mean,
depending on where we want to go with that,
I even want to start with like what is money?
Sure.
Cause we're throwing around the word currency and money and people talk about
gold and store of value.
And you know,
nick actually created bitgold,
which was,
uh,
some would argue a critical foundational predecessor to bitcoin.
Bitcoin had an additional breakthrough or two that an employed that big call did
not,
but,
but gold was the giant on whose shoulders bitcoin stands.
Uh,
and nick also created both the,
the phrase and the concept and the theory behind smart contracts,
which we're now starting to hear about in the context of other cryptocurrencies
like ethereum.
Uh,
but I,
I think we should just,
uh,
this is a complicated topic that it's worth just starting with like,
what is money?
If you ask 10 people in the street what money is,
you'd probably get 10 different answers.
Sure.
Um,
so I think it's important just to be rigorous about that.
And if you ask a lawyer,
we'll get an answer that's radically different than if you ask an economist as
well.
If you ask a lawyer,
they'll say something like an official government currency.
So of course bitcoin and goal,
you can't write checks for those because,
uh,
those are not legal official government currencies.
So that's the,
that's the kind of narrow,
modern legal definition.
Economists use the definition of medium of exchange,
which is a much broader definition,
but that also assumes that,
you know,
the only important transactions are people exchanging things,
which in our,
in our modern economy is a good assumption.
But if you actually go back to the origins of money,
which I've liked to study,
um,
you find things like inheritance and compensation for injuries as equivalent to
a modern lawsuit,
but not necessarily with governments and courts and more like wars to enforce
the fourth and the verdict and a bridewell.
There's certain fitness,
critical,
the Darwinian fitness at other animals can't do that.
Humans can.
And that form of,
I like to call it collectibles
because now I've extended the definition of money far broader than probably any
economist would want to.
But uh,
so I call us collectible,
so it's very similar.
So the Yurok Indians for example,
you shells too,
and they would have tattoo marks on their arm.
There were serious about their shells.
They would have tattoo marks in their arm to measure the lengths of shells and
that told you the denomination,
the value of,
of how valuable that show was,
which corresponds to how scarce it was in nature.
And they would use these for inheritance,
for injury compensation,
for bride wealth and so forth.
Yes.
It sounds like,
you know,
as I think that the common theory is that humans have only been using money for
a few thousand years,
but I think some of the work you've done in origins of money shows that actually
it's a hundred thousand years.
Yeah.
You can go back in the archaeological record and it's a puzzle for a hundred
thousand years and our Darwinian world that people lived in,
um,
quiet people do something.
So frivolous as you know,
adorn themselves with Shell necklaces.
Yet those are among the most common artifacts right up there with axes,
practical axes that you use to cut things in the archaeological record.
Yeah.
So I mean on,
on the money thing,
I've also tried to wrap my head around this and as Nick said,
yeah,
economists would say it's a medium of exchange,
uh,
as the historical record shows,
it's a store of value.
So even if you're not exchanging it,
you just want to go store valley.
You may not want to store bread or rocks or how's this?
So you store the image type of goal.
The transport.
Exactly.
And then it's also a unit of account.
So in other words,
like you have to denominate prices and something,
I'm not going to tell you how many loaves of bread a car costs.
So I need to be able to just pick a unit of account to don't judge.
I only have that occasionally.
So it is all of those things.
And I think one of the places where people fall down on cryptocurrencies
currencies,
they say,
well no one's using bitcoin to buy anything right now.
So it may not be fulfilling the medium of exchange function.
Uh,
but it is,
it may be fulfilling a different function,
that store of value.
It might be a Swiss bank account in everyone's pocket or in their mind or it
might be the defense against the Cypress style bank haircut
or it could be the the future that is here but not evenly distributed.
And,
and you can go to Palo Alto to Copa Cafe and buy coffee with bitcoin right now.
Yeah.
And within,
within my social circle,
uh,
there was a large group of people who will take bitcoin as legal tender.
Like you can go to them and settled debts in Bitcoin and they will happily take
it.
Yeah.
Or if you want to buy,
say a scientific abstracts or articles from a Russian website,
they may only take bitcoin as well.
Yes,
it does seem a little bubbly,
which is,
you know,
you kind of say,
well,
it's only money because everyone believed this money.
But,
uh,
one definition I really liked of,
money is money.
The bubble that never pops.
Okay.
So if we,
if,
if the tulip bubble had never popped,
we'd probably be dealing in tulips today.
Now it popped for fairly good reasons,
which is tulips make for a lousy money.
They're hard to store,
they're hard to transport their heart to sub divide.
Um,
but the crypto currencies,
uh,
actually are the exact opposite end of that scale.
They are easier to store,
easier to transport,
easier to subdivide,
um,
cheaper in many ways,
uh,
and more defensible than almost any other form of money or gold or commodity.
Now,
what makes,
since we're talking about money or currency,
what makes money valuable?
I think this might be interesting to dig into for a second because you have say
at certain points in time,
paper pegged to gold,
right?
And then the reading today,
because it's another word that I've seen a lot,
but aside from the car company,
I was not sure what Fiat really meant.
So if we're talking of valid,
don't even know what they're seeing even around anymore.
What distinguishes,
say,
cryptocurrency or makes cryptocurrency valuable?
Is it the rarity?
What are the factors that determine that?
Well,
I mean the scarcity is an essential essential part of it.
Um,
you,
if it starts in flooding on you,
then you're sure if it goes down.
So the scared cities quite essential to it.
Um,
other things are you want it to be easy and secure to store and transport.
And,
and Bitcoin has the advantage that you can send to people all over the world and
stored on a hardware wallet,
which is a fairly secure way to store it.
And the most important part of it,
what is a hardware wallet?
So hardware wallet,
so your normal computers are pretty insecure and that that's one of the stories
of blockchains is that,
um,
this distributed system is a lot more secure than an individual computer.
Um,
so you're going computer could have malware,
viruses and so forth.
So hardware,
while it's a separate piece,
like on Usb stick you plug in has its own chip on it and the bit coin your
private key gets stored on that chip rather than on the computer.
Got It.
Yeah.
There's a zillion ways to a bitcoin.
You could do it on your computer,
but the new computers connected to the Internet security hole.
You could put it in an online exchange,
but then you're just trusting an unregulated bank.
Um,
you can put it in a hardware wallet,
which says Nix had a dedicated device.
Um,
you can put it on a piece of paper and stick it in your bank account.
Is that in cold storage or if it's cold storage?
Yeah,
that's cold storage.
What he says where I know the words but not what they mean.
This is,
this is one of them.
Yeah.
This is one of the craziest things about this concept because money in money and
speech turned out to be the same thing.
Money,
information,
math.
They are the same thing.
So in a big coin world,
I can literally write down my bitcoin address and keys on a piece of paper and
put in a safety deposit box.
And it's basically in cold storage.
I could even put it in my head,
I can memorize the key phrases and I could cross borders with $1 billion in my
brain.
Um,
so in that it's a very powerful but mind bending literally concept in that
sense.
Is this a point where it makes sense to talk about smart contracts or is that a
non sequitur?
No,
where's there,
is there a good bridge?
Yeah,
no,
I think,
I think we should get into it first.
I,
I want to make sure that we understand what blockchains in bitcoin are,
right.
Might be worth going into.
Like what are the key innovations that enabled bitcoin?
And I'll leave you to dictate when this makes sense or either of you guys,
but the article that you sent about
the,
I guess,
fat protocol layer.
Right.
And get it to that later.
Okay.
We'll get there.
That's a little teaser for folks.
Uh,
I'll let you lead with them.
So I think it's worth getting into like what is the bitcoin computer,
right?
Cause there is basically you can abstract and think of Bitcoin is running on a
blockchain computer.
Uh,
and maybe nick can take a stab at defining what it is.
By the way,
this is one of those things where I think if you asked 10 different people in
cryptocurrencies what bitcoin is and what a blockchain is and what watching
computer is,
you'll get 10 different answers.
You know,
some people are more qualified than others.
Oh it's,
it's also just,
it's new.
It's hard to figure it out.
These are very abstract concepts,
ideas being turned into code and um,
they are all,
bitcoin is almost to computers.
What,
what like quantum mechanics is to physics.
It throws a lot of people in the field off.
Well it's also like quantum physics because you have a lot of uh,
well intentioned like hippies and new agey people who will misappropriate it and
use it completely incorrectly.
Absolutely.
Not to say there are a lot of new agey hippie people getting into
cryptocurrency.
There might be,
but,
uh,
I think you also have that challenge,
the layers of understanding,
like,
I don't know how to write code for a Merkle tree.
I don't know how to take a part of bitcoin block and analyze it.
Um,
so in some level I'm still,
you know,
a new agey hippie trying to figure it out.
Um,
but I think it's worth getting into like,
what is the blockchain computer and how does it enable Bitcoin,
I guess first of all,
before dropping to that.
And another important concept to the architecture that hasn't been mentioned yet
is replication.
So there's thousands of copies of these things running on what are called full
nodes all over the world.
And those are servers,
right?
Right.
So there,
there are servers that can be laptops or larger machines,
but,
uh,
there are thousands of them running all over the world.
So anybody who has a copy of this can their machine and do a full validation for
itself.
And it's kind of the most secure way to run,
run a cryptocurrency.
Yeah.
Sorry,
sorry to interrupt you.
But basically what's going on is if I give Tim $10 and then Tim gives nick those
$10 the way we,
you track of it as to a piece of paper or in the old days where the Yurok
Indians,
it would be a shell of a certain measurement.
But now with Bitcoin there's a ledger.
We basically just keep track in a ledger entry that neval moved this $10 to Tim.
Tim moved the $10 to nick.
Now the problem is who maintains the sanctity of that ledger?
Can You just forge that ledger?
So historically the central bank would maintain the sanctity of the ledger or
the fact that you have a certain dollar bill with a serial number and it
maintains the sanctity of the ledger.
But now bitcoin has the craziest answer you can imagine,
but it turns out to work,
which is everybody has a copy of the ledger.
So every one of the bitcoin network who's running a node keeps a copy of the
ledgers from the dawn of Bitcoin till now.
And that is a testament to the computing power and memory that we have available
in,
in modern computers that people can do this at home.
You can run a full bitcoin node.
Where do you keep a copy of every single bitcoin transaction from the dawn time
til now?
And all these computers running together essentially validate with each other
like our,
our ledgers or same are we using the same ledger who's ledger is correct in case
as a disagreement.
Uh,
and that's where kind of all the blockchain comes in doing all this
cryptography.
And then another thing that's replicated besides the data and the uh,
um,
integrity,
cryptography we talked about,
um,
his code computer programs and kind of the second definition of smart contracts,
we'll get into the first definition later.
But the second definition is simply describing this code,
this replicated that's running on all these nodes and a,
that code can do things like enforce on bitcoin and can do some fairly simple
things that add some sophistication or like require multiple signatures to do a
spend for example.
So like you can think of signature authority and office where multiple people
have to sign off on something.
You can set up your bitcoin to do that.
Using one of these smart contracts on these pieces of code replicated.
I might be taking us back or taking us ahead or neither.
Ah,
a wandering through the blockchain.
It's complicated.
Yeah.
It's a smart contract.
In essence.
Are you taking what would rely on human beings and embedding it into the
technology so that there's,
you don't have to rely on standard set of ethics,
reliable set of behavior.
Is that a smart contract?
Yeah,
so to some extent there,
there are some areas of,
of contracts,
I'm kinds of contractual clauses usually,
but not always associated with the financial aspects of the contract that you
can,
they're really logically structured and you can code that into the computer,
put it on the blockchain and then it runs over the really high integrity.
And that means that somebody in Albania can do a smart contract with somebody in
Zimbabwe.
And to the extent that they can formalize there,
deal mathematically with through this logic,
um,
code.
They don't have to rely on the Albanian authorities or the Zimbabwe authorities.
They can just do business directly.
And uh,
you had a great term for this.
This is getting into the driver's is wet code,
right?
So dry being computer based,
well being potentially the legal ease and the head of a lawyer in Albania and
the legal ease in the head of a lawyer in Zimbabwe,
which is going to be a whole whole just slew of mess potentially.
Right.
So I like to think all that legal easy.
See in a contract as,
as a,
as a program that runs on the brains of a lawyer.
It doesn't usually run on north brains of normal people.
This is going to,
yeah,
I'm trying to take us to too far field what we're talking about.
How did you become interested in contracts?
So it's part of I guess libertarian ideology,
but it's also part,
I went to law school and it's also part of law school one o one that property in
contract law,
that kind of the two fundamental building blocks of our commercial society.
Yeah.
So I was interested in in how do you enforce those cyberspace?
I don't meet many people.
I meet people who have say JD Mba or j d Ph d I don't meet many people who have
j d and computer science degree and Lo and libertarian.
On top of that,
I ended up Rotarian on top of that,
although I have heard there are some libertarians running around the bay area,
a Jd.
Currently I'm a libertarian.
I've been told relatively to the average person in silicon valley.
I live in San Francisco and own guns and they're like,
you're a libertarian.
I'm like,
is that it really?
Is that easy?
I got my Mike,
my card.
Okay.
How did you end up doing both of those degrees?
I haven't run into that before.
The law degree is in large part based on smart contracts and wanting to do a
reality check of the stuff I'd thought of as a computer scientist.
I see,
so the computer science came first?
Yeah,
and then the J D was right.
Went to study the wet code then?
Yeah.
Now that I know how a computer works,
let me go look at an advocates and see what that's like.
Okay.
Very cool.
Yeah,
so,
so I think some of this is smart contracts,
which by the way,
as I said earlier,
nick created not just the concept of the theory behind it.
Uh,
smart contracts are essentially taking that wet code,
converting into dry code and then putting it inside blockchain.
So it's immutable after awhile that it's,
it becomes a fly trapped in amber.
If we made an agreement and the simplest smart contract,
by the way,
it's just I gave you money and you got the money,
that's a very,
very simple contract that got fulfilled.
So,
but you can put much more complex.
So a contract is a promise and fulfillment of promise or is there an easier way
to think about it?
Because what I think contract,
I think of all these clauses are right,
termination,
arbitration term,
et Cetera.
I think of all these because they look at Winchester and contracts
now.
So,
um,
you can think of the primordial granddaddy of all smart contracts is the vending
machine.
So vending machine,
um,
in contract law terms,
it verifies a performance you put in your quarter and it verifies,
you put in the quarter through its mechanical.
I'm talking about old fashioned machines here.
It has logic in that says,
okay,
you put in a quarter the soda cost a dime.
So I'm going to give you a,
a diamond in Nickelback and the soda you selected.
So you can think of writing this in a contract.
Tediously um,
that,
uh,
you know,
if,
if the party of the first puts in a quarter,
you know,
the cardio the second we'll give them back.
But of course you want to do this and machine,
right?
I'll get the lawyers.
Any idea,
it's verifying our performance.
On the one hand,
somebody,
it's observing that somebody did their payment are their other performance of a
contractual deal and on their hands automating and performance,
it's dispensing,
dispensing the guts.
So the colors are kind of the two basic things smart contracts can do.
They verify somebody's performance,
um,
and they automate performance.
Now,
the third thing is if you have another,
there's a bunch of stuff that's inherently what most of this stuff that you can
code and the smart contracts as those two kinds of things are like payments and
various financial conditions.
You can do a lot of financial stuff like um,
options
and collateralize loans and so forth,
uh,
futures.
But uh,
for things that are inherently wet though,
nobody's figured out how to have the computer verify or automate to performance
yet.
Um,
you can,
you know,
invoke an arbitrator,
a signature structured like multisig dab humans approve certain steps.
In what case would be an example of where you or someone else might want
multi-six in that universe.
If you're doing something with an escrow,
for example,
that you have the person or persons responsible for the collateral verifying
that the contract was performed,
then they can free up the collateral.
Got It.
So if you wanted to buy a house that had to do inspections,
Wendy's,
bitcoin,
right?
Yeah.
It'd be good to situation.
And there are things you can do now with smart contracts,
which you call on chain,
where you can have all the money and the collateral and the escrow and the data
as close to computerize as possible.
So the stuff that people are starting to do with smart contracts and now it's
pretty mind blowing.
Can we talk about the article you sent me?
I know it seems like it might not be the right [inaudible] was very helpful to
me.
Sure.
So do you want to dig into that?
So there's this,
there's this concept of uh,
what bitcoin and etherium and these other cryptocurrencies are doing.
Um,
is there,
they're the new protocols and what does a protocol,
a protocol is kind of like a God,
now I'm going to get trapped in definitions,
but a protocol is sort of how computers,
it's a standard for how computers exchange information.
Um,
so for example,
you and I speaking the English language is a form of protocol,
but then also like each day,
DTP.
Yeah,
I'm supposed to pause every five seconds and then you're supposed to get a
chance to speak.
That's part of the protocol.
We say hello to each other as a greeting.
So we have verbal packets like TCI and also another protocol.
And on the Internet these protocols are TCP Ip,
http,
SMTP.
Every time your email gets sent from one server to another,
it's using the SMTP simple mail transfer protocol.
And these protocols power the Internet.
Um,
and the assumption that was made in the early days of the Internet was that,
well Ben,
with this cheap servers are cheap,
hardware is cheap,
so it's free.
If I want to send you a packet,
it's free.
If you want to receive the packet,
It doesn't cost anything,
but those assumptions are breaking down.
Um,
we have denial of service attacks,
which is basically your computer demands resource from my computer that I'm
saying no,
but you're asking so many times for free that it just overwhelms me.
Spam is another example.
I can send you a zillion email that hardly any costs,
but it costs you a lot of attention.
So these free protocols are,
are becoming poor assumptions.
The worst place for a poor assumption on a protocol is a protocol for exchanging
money.
If I say,
Tim,
I want to give you $10,
that has to be scarce in some way.
It can't just be,
it can't be a free transaction,
right?
Cause it's money's exchanging hands.
So we need a concept of protocols that underlies scarce resources,
that,
that allocate scarce resources.
And what's going on is cryptocurrencies and blockchains are creating these,
uh,
what are now being called fact protocols.
Uh,
and we'll put an article in the,
in the show notes about this,
but fat protocols are protocols,
uh,
that actually exchange scarce value.
And they keep data in the protocol.
They maintain
data.
That's the key piece,
right?
Or in a way,
yeah,
there's two key pieces.
One is scarcity,
which is a regulated by a token.
So in the bitcoin protocol,
the scarce pieces of the bitcoin itself and the protocol is about the exchange
of money and the token is bitcoin.
And then there's data that you can put on the blockchain.
Like,
I could,
for example,
take a,
uh,
an article that I wrote,
I could hash it the one way crypto Hash,
put it in the blockchain,
prove that it came from me,
and then it gets trapped in the amber again,
like the fly and no one can undo it later.
And as it's secured by the value of the blockchain,
so the,
these,
these new protocols,
these fat protocols are very different.
They're gonna exchange.
They're going to enable a new kind of internet that we did not have before.
Um,
that's a thesis of kind of the fat protocol argument
just for people listening who like me were trying to find their way their way
through the darkness with a lot of this stuff.
When I read that piece,
which is on the union square ventures website.
Yep.
Hi Fred and guys,
uh,
I'm blanking on the name of the author.
Very good,
Jill Montenegro.
There we go.
Yeah.
And the,
the,
the before and after example that was given,
or one of them was you have these thin protocols,
http,
et Cetera.
And then you have these services built on top of them that becomes silos of
information,
whether that's Facebook,
Google,
whatever it might be.
And then they developed their own means of authentication and so on.
So you have these captive stores of information,
you have security risks on top of that.
So now perhaps you are doing your banking through a web server.
And conversely,
when you then have the,
and I hate to use this word,
but sort of the democratized data that is built into the protocol itself,
saying the case of Bitcoin,
where now you have all of these nodes that have,
for the purposes of illustration,
every transaction start to finish.
Uh,
it's more secure,
you're less captive.
And it conforms to the libertarian slash ion rand ideals that we were talking
about earlier.
And the illustration that was given that I thought was fascinating and may or
may not hold true for for decades,
but it was that you have protocols that they're necessary but not valuable right
there.
They're available and they're like utility to the public and then you have
these,
these billion dollar multibillion dollar companies built on top of it,
Facebook,
Google,
et cetera.
Then you have conversely bitcoin,
which has a market cap of X.
I don't know what it is,
current 5 billion today,
and then the company is built on top of it are intentionally small but in the
tens or hundreds of millions at most.
Right.
So it's a complete flip in terms of
yeah,
the value is getting captured by the fat protocol.
Yeah.
I do recommend this article.
It's actually John,
sorry Joel Manet grow.
I got his last name wrong,
but uh,
he wrote a brilliant piece on this,
but the thesis is that uh,
because these protocols are storing your identity and data on the,
on the protocol and the protocol itself,
the applications don't capture you as much.
You're not stuck in the applications and the value is captured by the tokens in
the protocol.
Does that mean this is,
this is just putting on the investor hat for a second,
that people are going to be incentivized to just create more and more different
types of cryptocurrency and then reserve to try to capture that.
That's exactly what's happening.
So I wrote a post on this called the bitcoin model for crowdfunding and this is
a couple of years back and I thought these things called APP coins would show
up,
but for every application rather than going and raising VC money,
you just attach a token to it.
You crowdfunded and that's kind of what's happening now with what they call icls
initial coin offerings.
And there's been hundreds and hundreds of these and you know it's a little
bubbly.
In fact,
it's very bubbly.
A lot of them are getting bid up out of control.
Some of it comes from the fact that a few of these protocols do need their own
token.
They can't use bitcoin,
but most of the times it's really just the developers have an incentive to
create a token bolted on and try and capture the value.
But it's,
but it's a,
it's an interesting model for funding,
open source software and protocols that didn't really exist before
our bubbles.
A bad thing.
And this is,
this is something I've also been reading about that I'm really,
I don't know if you have any,
any thoughts on this,
but in many people's minds,
bubbles are a bad thing.
But I read a counterargument for the first time today,
which was,
you know,
after a bubble bursts,
then you have out of the money investors who are incentivized in Rick in
regaining the value of what has declined by creating services and applications
that are now these sort of thin applications,
which then preserves the sort of long term viability of x,
whatever that might be.
Which I hadn't really considered before.
Well,
there is a sense in which many bubbles are unavoidable because the future is a
genuinely uncertain place.
Yeah.
Especially this is,
these are reflexive industries where,
uh,
you know,
the notion of reflexivity is like,
my prediction alone changes the potential outcome.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
the extreme example is like a prediction market.
Predicting the death of somebody.
If there's enough money on that,
it turns into an assassination market.
Um,
so,
uh,
bubbles are inherently,
I think just apart of any system that involves in network effects.
If I think and money is the ultimate network effect,
I accept US dollars is money because you accept,
you thought was his money and so on.
If we all believe that,
if we all believe tomorrow the tulips were valuable,
again,
we'd be trading in Tulips.
So if I believe that you're going to accept this as money,
then I want to put more money in and you want to put more money in.
The network effects sort of creates a bubble.
And as Nick said,
the future is in an uncertain place.
So sometimes we'll be wrong or we have to step back.
There'll be a little bit of a releasing of energy.
Um,
I read something a couple of years back that said that showed that as the stock
market is becoming more efficient,
it's actually becoming more volatile.
It's not becoming less fall.
It has becoming more volatile because it's reacting faster and faster to
information changes.
That's like the story of why you can look at long term capital management where
there are all sorts of high frequency trading you.
So you have not only humans,
right,
who are in increasingly interconnected,
but you also have computers
right now.
There's a,
there's a big train irrelevant in China that causes a political change that
causes a,
the futures market in China to shift that causes the U s stock market to go
down.
Right?
Computers are getting better and better at absorbing that information,
extrapolating it out the consequences.
And uh,
and so the markets have become more and more volatile.
So over time we should see bubbles form faster,
pop more quickly.
Uh,
and I think they'll fall into a power law distribution.
Like there,
there'll be ones that'll be really large,
there'll be ones that'll be really small and,
but this idea that the future is going to be very smooth and linear and
predictable is a human illusion.
Yeah.
Uh,
I think that's fair assumption.
Nick,
what are the biggest misconceptions or common misunderstandings related to
cryptocurrency or bitcoin or,
or like what is smart people get wrong?
Uh,
if,
if there's anything where you're like,
God,
this like x drives me nuts.
If I hear one more person who should know better.
Well,
we can get into the whole block side just because there's this parameter.
Um,
we shouldn't,
but probably we'll talk about it a little bit there.
There's this,
there's this,
it's a technical security parameter.
It's called the block size.
How the general public glommed onto this.
I do not know,
but there's,
there's an obsessive group of people who think of this as some kind of
artificial barrier to more transactions per second on bitcoin.
Really it's its job as it's,
it's a fence preventing people from over homing flooding to network with lots of
transactions at the full nodes I talked about can handle that.
That transaction history keeps building and building.
He had a very simple level.
If,
if every computer storing a copy of every transaction,
then you can't have an infinite number of transactions because the computer will
explode.
And so what you'd do is if you,
if you keep increasing the number of transactions to too quickly,
then you only allow a smaller and smaller shrinking set of computers to run the
code,
um,
which reduces who,
who's actually in charge of the security.
Before you might've had a million computers,
then you're down to 100,000 big computers,
then there's only a few thousand large players.
Then eventually down to five people who can store the entire history and then
you're basically back to central banks.
So the debate is should we keep allowing more and more transactions because what
if people,
everyone wants to buy a Starbucks using it a bitcoin or it should be only
limited to very high value transactions and instead the diversity of people
who can,
who can run the code.
Yeah,
I mean this shouldn't even be a public debate.
It's like the public debating and voting on the graphite reactor setting or
graphite
things,
settings that prevent a nuclear actor from over heating and melting down.
And I let them debate the bike shed and there there are certain things you
should let the engineers decide.
And this is one of them.
And uh,
for some reason there's just a whole group of people who want to want to pull
out those graphite moderator rods and have it going full steam.
Yeah.
One of the problems with the bitcoin is that
because a lot of people hold a little bit of Bitcoin,
everyone has a financial incentive,
and they're all talking their own book and they get really emotional about it.
Nick had this great tweet that I liked,
said,
best way to destroy your investment in Bitcoin is to gather an internet mob to
go and redesign bitcoin.
Right.
And that's a little bit of what's happening right now.
Well,
you were saying,
you know,
before we started recording that a lot of you've,
you've never seen so many scientists to be uncivil towards one another.
Yeah.
I think,
I think the,
the worst Twitter is Trump Twitter,
where everyone's getting outraged over politics all the time.
But the second worst Twitter right now is blockchain Twitter,
where you will have PhDs from Cornell and university of Maryland and all kinds
of credential places,
literally calling each other horrific names online,
a casting aspersions,
other people's moral cat,
moral character,
calling them trolls,
uh,
dragging them through the mud and they each have their little local tribal mob
behind them over things like the block size debate,
which has an exist,
you know,
it's actually in the parameter settings in a nuclear reactor.
Well,
it's a,
I mean it makes me think of,
they're a bunch of sort of expressions that jumped to mind.
You're saying you're talking their own book.
So the uninformed as to be very careful about asking a Barbara if they need a
haircut.
Right.
You need to know what the incentives are.
Exactly.
And I'm sure people have heard the expression,
it's not very flattering,
but men is as loyal as his options might be.
You know,
a scientist or someone who is otherwise civil is as civil as their incentives,
right?
Yes.
Once you have enough to gain or lose.
Yeah.
Incentives are everything.
Charlie Munger says,
if you can be working on incentives,
don't work on anything else.
Uh,
and,
and it's that,
you know,
going back to Bitcoin,
the bitcoin designed for a second big bitcoin is brilliantly designed because
the underlying game theory and incentives.
Yeah.
Could we talk just for a second about what is bitcoin?
So we talked about cryptocurrency.
What makes,
what made bitcoin and what makes bitcoin unique,
if,
if that's,
if we could maybe talk about that.
You can think about it in a couple laters.
The most important and fundamental layer is a computer science later layer where
we prove that it would take 51% of the computational power of the hash rate to
attack this thing and do things like double spend
basically changing that ledger,
right?
So it's like you can't change the ledger.
The beauty is the fly in amber analogy is a great one because once we,
you and I done a transaction,
then network has agreed on the transaction going back and then doing it is
nearly impossible.
But while that amber is being laid down,
I can still be some mischief.
Right?
So one of the big misconceptions of Bitcoin is that,
well,
if 51% of the computers in the network,
which are run by people called miners,
the coal miners,
this the old,
and now you're digging for gold,
so they're digging for bitcoin.
But really what they're doing is they're laying down that amber,
if 51% of these people collude,
then does that mean they can go back and change the ledger?
No,
they can't change the existing leisure,
but they end cause mischief with the current transaction or the current layer
that's being laid down.
It's one of the big misconceptions.
I'm so sorry to interrupt.
Yeah.
So that's the one of the computer science limitations of it and,
and the other one is doing software upgrades.
Software upgrades kind of changed the rules even more.
So.
Yeah.
And so those two things end up getting,
especially it's a software upgrades end up getting very politicized.
Yeah.
Bitcoin fundamentally what,
what's going on?
It's uh,
uh,
nick first create a bit gold.
Right.
Do you wanna talk about what the innovation bit cold was or how the big goal
system work and then we can layer on bitcoin on sure.
But called was inspired by a kind of this origins of money research and how do
I,
and also there was an area called private banking or you could take your bank
note and go up to bank windowing.
It gold and the bank,
the paper money we have today looks very much like these bank notes did,
um,
a thing I call authority resemblance or sort of faking and pretending to that
this is still really valuable stuff.
Um,
and the illusion works apparently for the most part,
but uh,
but they used to work very differently.
Used to be able to go up to window and get actual gold for your paper.
Yeah.
It's between green flat until they've seen it.
Yeah,
it was debt.
Now it's just the paper itself.
You've got to just trust the paper itself from the Federal Reserve.
But um,
in any case,
I was inspired by what
peaches,
a Fiat currency.
I never actually,
Fiat currency is just a paper that's backed by nothing.
So before it was shells,
then we went to gold,
then we went to gold back paper and now we're down to just paper.
Okay.
Creating that bank note itself is easy enough to do.
That's basically what paypal and a company I was working for called digicash
David Shalman stuff.
We're doing that trust based paper note that was issued by some central
authority,
but I became dissatisfied with that because then at the end of the day,
you want to go to that window and get something else.
That's more what I call trust minimized.
So gold is valuable all over the world.
If you go back to these more primitive tribes,
the gold and the shells and so forth,
you know,
you can pay them to next time,
next time I'm over all your neighbors would accept them as well.
They wouldn't accept your,
your IOU because you know you're not going to trust people.
You could go word war with tomorrow,
but they would accept,
um,
the shells or the copper beads of the gold beads,
the first gold artifact by the ways of being the first copper artifact.
Those apparently the most important,
earliest uses of,
of,
of metal,
not knives or weapons or tools or so forth in any case.
So,
um,
so I was looking for this trust minimizing like how to do this in cyberspace.
Um,
since I had read stuff,
I know it's not just some magical property of gold that makes it valuable and
other things aren't or something.
Um,
or some intrinsic,
you know,
it started off,
you can use it in elect,
you know,
electrical circuits or so forth.
Now there's something about,
um,
when I call the unfordable costliness of at the scarcity of it,
then naturally trust,
minimize scarcity of it.
You don't have to trust somebody to keep it scarce.
I tried to recreate this in cyberspace using proof of work,
um,
Adam back hash cash.
And so basically the bit gold design did that.
And then it used a replication technique,
which had originally been developed that,
I apologize,
can backtrack,
but the proof of work,
what do you,
what do you mean by that?
Okay,
so proof of work is a mathematical puzzle,
a computation that the computer does that says,
okay,
you have to solve this.
And we know from computer science it'll take so long to solve.
Um,
but we also know from computer science that it's,
it's a kind of a problem that you can improve the hardware,
which is why everybody uses design specialized hardware for it.
Got It.
Now,
because,
um,
unlike normal cryptography,
it's,
well,
it's not even unlike normal cryptography in that way,
but um,
it's something that you can do a lot faster if you have hardware
proof.
Proof of work is basically,
you have to,
you have people here who are basically laying down a layer of amber on the fly,
right?
And so they have to basically commit resources to do it.
It has to be costly to do that.
You need scarcity in this system,
right?
So that's that scarcity is created by the costliness of the computing power that
you throw at it.
So basically the more computer power you want to throw at the bitcoin network,
the more seriously the bitcoin network takes your vote.
And we have to know your computing power is dedicated to the bitcoin network.
It's not,
you know,
off surfing the internet or doing something else.
So you have to commit it to doing work just for the bitcoin network.
And the proof is through mathematical functions.
So you basically have puzzles to solve the bitcoin network,
the algorithms give the computer's puzzles to solve.
If the computer solve the puzzles,
they can prove that yes,
I put economic value,
time,
heat,
power,
computation into solving this problem.
So now I get a vote on what the ledger looks like and I get a chance to be paid
in coin.
So this is what the miner to do.
The miners do the work to secure the network using computers.
They provide that proof to the network.
The network pays them in new coins that it's my,
that is minting.
Got It.
Anyway,
so,
um,
no,
Satoshi had an innovation where he uses this proof of work as part of the
security and for people who don't know,
who is Sitoshi who that name,
well it's some unknown character out there that has disappeared.
Yeah.
Our group.
Whoever,
whoever created bit coin,
you know,
obviously built on Nick's work,
built on a health fund,
his work a way.
There were a couple of great computer scientists who did this work.
Um,
but whoever actually built the working implementation because I think nick you
had,
you had the theory of big goal but you're not as serious and a programmer to
create
bit cold.
Well I'm a serious programmer but I was too,
uh,
didn't get around to programming bit cold.
So yeah,
it was a design
and so whoever created Bitcoin,
it probably group,
cause it looks like a very sophisticated effort.
Did it pseudonymously or anonymously and the,
the,
the name that they used was Satoshi Nakamoto,
Vic olders.
It's designed on the 32 uses proof of work as a,
what I call unforgivable costliness or diction strain.
The supply curves,
you know,
it's scarce and is big innovation was to,
well let me backtrack and describe a little more big old.
So,
um,
there's a,
a protocol design for to keep airplanes from crashing because you don't want
your computer to go crash on an airplane and cause the airplane to crash,
right?
Right.
You want to your computer to be able to crash an airplane that the airline
itself going on.
So,
um,
what you need is to distribute the surrounds.
You have several chips all around the airplane and then they talk to each other.
And then if they get contradictory information,
they do what you might call voting.
They'll pick the majority,
um,
and considered that to be the correct one.
And that turns out to be,
they mathematically proved that this was the optimal model,
given those assumptions that you know,
how many chips there are and so forth.
Um,
and this is called Byzantine consensus.
So I took that and used it for this replication business to replicate the data
around the ledger round,
um,
with a Merkle tree for the transaction history and so forth.
Um,
what's the Toshi did was a really big innovation besides of course actually
making software people could use,
which I never did.
He is the proof of work in security subs on the Internet.
You can't count your chips securely.
You don't know.
I have a chip in the tail and a chip and the wing and so forth.
The sock puppet problem people,
one person can be pretend to be a hundred and we're one computer can pretend to
be a hundred Satoshi based it on proof of work basis security,
that voting.
Like if the preponderance of the Hash rate tells me that the transaction is
history's been updated in such,
in such a way,
then that's,
that's it.
And again,
that's good.
Up to 51%
and swearing the 51% attack comes from basically one computation.
One vote is the way to think about it.
Got It.
Um,
and,
and actually one of the,
one of the problems that people have with the bitcoin network is designed,
so basically a Bitcoin,
you have all these computers around the world that are joining together to
create this shared blockchain computer.
They get votes in proportion to how much CPU power they're allocating.
They vote on what the valid transactions or that then go into this ledger and
get sealed in the ember of the blockchain.
And the whole system kind of works.
But a naive person looking from the outside,
as you said,
like the hippies coming into blockchains,
one of their first objections is you're wasting all this computer power.
You're wasting all this energy.
Um,
you're wasting all this network resources because they're constantly chatting
with each other and network.
These computers are broadcasting packets,
these are all the time.
And they just say it's wasteful.
Um,
but,
uh,
and,
and I think that was an argument that a lot of people make.
And even I kind of fell for that one where I was like,
okay,
you know,
eventually someone will come up with a better solution than proof of work and go
to proof of stake or a few other kinds of ideas that have been thrown around.
And then nick just recently wrote this brilliant piece,
uh,
on social scalability.
Um,
and by the,
you got a doctorate recently,
an honorary doctorate.
Oh yeah.
At the university Universidad Francisco mark wine.
Yeah.
And a Guatemalan,
what is your doctorate in?
It's and social sciences and also an honorary professorship as well.
So yeah,
that's great.
That's a very long,
the only a social scientist I'm gonna talk at this level,
but I mean that's the kind of honorary doctorate they give.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it's lots of luminary.
So yeah,
I'm very honored to have that.
Yeah.
They cited your social scalability article and so,
uh,
the social scalability argument,
I thought it was a really powerful one.
I don't know if you want to try and summarize that for the listeners.
I'm sure.
So the idea,
the basic idea is that if you look at a graph of human capabilities,
it's basically flat where the same Iq is.
We had,
you know,
um,
so there's a small thing called the Flynn effect,
but an Internet,
um,
you know,
a hundred thousand years ago,
our brains were roughly the same size as they are today.
And a computers on the other hand have been,
you know,
doubling every few years,
their capabilities,
um,
in various ways,
their memory,
their CPU power,
a network bandwidth and so forth.
And so,
and you can think of this in the future and get into all sorts of speculation
about the future.
But what I like to think of it as,
as we have this whole surplus,
we've built up of resources and yet we're still doing things institutionally
with armies of bureaucrats and stuff.
Very similar to what we're doing.
You know,
when computers were,
you know,
a thousands of the power they are now or millions of the power they are now or
what they were doing in the Mongol Empire.
So in any case,
so can we do some substitutions?
Can we substitute take advantage of this great surplus?
So computer scientists are normally an engineer's,
are normally trained to think,
optimize the machine,
make the machine itself really efficient.
What I'm saying is that you can think the other way.
Are there ways to make the machine a lot less efficient and give you some
greater capability so that such as,
for example,
the ability of somebody in Albania to pay somebody in Zimbabwe,
um,
without going through a trusted intermediary or human bureaucracy,
ways to do that.
You know,
even if they cost a lot more and look really bad to an engineer likes to think
about efficiency.
So,
and pick coins,
a great example of that.
It's a proof of work,
um,
as part of its security.
And,
and in my mind to create that,
that scarcity,
stepping back for a second,
what separates humans from other animals is that we are social across genetic
boundaries.
So you know,
even the end of the falls,
you can have 150 neanderthals on a battlefield because they're all genetically
related.
But you can have 5,000 homo sapiens in the battlefield because they believe in
the abstract idea of Christianity and they can communicate that story to each
other,
right?
And so bitcoin enables a form of social scalability where it allows now humans
who don't know each other,
who don't trust each other,
who may never see each other again and don't even reveal their identities or
locations to each does still transact securely,
not just with money,
but also with contracts.
Any complex logic they can dream up that they can code up,
they can do it through this very slow and very inefficient computer,
but it removes all these layers of humans,
bureaucrats and toll takers from the operation.
Well,
right?
So you're able to exceed the Dunbar number,
Yeah,
the 150 people Dunbar number.
So you're basically trading computational scalability
for social scalability.
And just to maybe put it another way,
and I'd love to be corrective,
this isn't right,
but uh,
there's a,
there's another quote of yours,
nick,
that I really liked.
Trusted third parties are security holes I think relates to this very nicely.
And there is a bit on blockchain computers that I think is relevant.
So why,
why make the tradeoff?
Why allow all of this inefficiency,
right?
And I'm not going to read this entire thing,
but it,
it's the blockchain computer.
This distributed blockchain computers much slower and more costly than a web
server,
but one very rough estimate about 10,000 times slower and more costly.
But since on the blockchain,
you're,
you're running the portion of an application that needs to be the most reliable
and secure what you call a fiduciary called a code because the downside risk is
so high,
you can afford to have tons of inefficiency,
particularly with hardware that is dropping in cost and increasing in capability
year on year,
right?
Yeah.
We,
we've accumulated this great,
great hardware capacity surplus that,
that we're only starting to take advantage of and so you can use that to do like
the proof of work,
the very,
the strong security protocols that take some computational effort and the also
the making the copies.
We have lots of memory,
lots of disk space,
lots of bandwidth,
not vast amounts but enough to you can,
you can take a small transaction and replicated around the world,
make thousands of copies that helps create stuff fly in amber.
In fact where you can't deny it later cause everybody's got copies of it.
Yeah.
In a way like,
uh,
I think you had a definition of social skill that in your article it's not
precise but close enough where you basically said one way to estimate how
socially scalable technology is is by how many people can use it.
Right.
And uh,
when it comes to cash today,
like,
like the u s dollar,
it's accepted probably the most widely accepted currency in the world,
but we're still talking hundreds of millions to maybe a billion people can
really use it in their everyday life.
Whereas bitcoin in theory,
when it's,
uh,
when it's adopted,
can be used by anyone to pay anyone.
As long as you connected to the internet and everyone's connecting to the
internet,
it scales better.
I'm going to ask a question that came up a lot and it's one that I don't have
any,
any ability to answer.
Is it possible to,
for any government entity to regulate bitcoin or crypto currencies out of
existence?
If so,
where would you put the likelihood of of such a thing happening or being able to
be,
why are you,
because
he's copies are all over the world.
They're never going to get rid of these copies.
So he's always going to have the transaction history and can start it up again.
Yup.
So at that,
and it's sense makes it very difficult to regulate.
There are easier parts of it to regulate such as the exchanging of Fiat currency
or local currency to bitcoin and back and forth.
Those still happen through centralized exchanges,
which both makes them fairly easy to regulate and also it makes them insecure,
trusted.
Third parties are security holes,
so if you want to get in and out of Bitcoin,
you're usually doing it through these centralized exchanges and that's where the
vast majority of of thefts and hacks of of Bitcoin have occurred.
These extended,
the exchanges essentially ended up like banks.
They're honeypots,
so regulators and honeypots for thieves.
How do you buy or sell,
say bitcoin without going through you today?
You do that through a central,
through an exchange.
There's also sort of local meetups.
There's like a,
there's these sites like local bitcoins and there's a few others.
There's a big one coming up in China and now we can just sort of coordinate a
meetup with somebody in a dark alley and you exchange cash for bitcoin.
Um,
so that people can fall back to that.
And,
and the volume on those kinds of distributed exchanges has gone up a lot.
Um,
if you look at bit torrent,
which is the file sharing technologies are accounts where like a ridiculous
amount of internet traffic,
Bram Cohen and invented it.
Um,
you know,
that thing on given day can account for being a quarter to half of Internet
traffic and you can bet the governments and it had been trying to shut that down
because right now the governments are overzealous and nothing in so much as
enforcing copyright law.
I mean,
you want to drive,
you know,
you want to drop the full weight of the federal government on you.
Um,
you either engage in terrorist activity or we violet cooperate.
They'll like roughly equivalent,
right?
They'll drop helicopters and your house in New Zealand,
you ask him.com for violating copyright law,
even if you've never set foot in the u s such an understated lifestyle,
he was so subtle,
even know how to call it on to him.
Um,
but yeah,
so,
uh,
I don't,
I don't think governments can really shut it down.
Uh,
not only that,
but any government that really embraces bitcoin or any of these cryptocurrency
doesn't have to be big coin.
They can even kind of start up a new one if they want it to,
is just going to benefit so much from really owning the money that's native to
the Internet.
You know,
I called Bitcoin the Internet of money because it's,
uh,
it's really native to how code works.
So if you really want to future proof yourself,
it's like,
imagine if the u s crack down on it and said no more cryptocurrencies.
That would be saying like saying no more http.
Right.
And the country that did adopt HTP.
And by the way,
this is the HTP of money.
What ended up so much better off that used to be shooting yourself in the head.
Um,
so I think smart people,
smart money in the u s already recognizes that and so it's seeping up into the
government where they're figuring out that yeah,
we could,
we could be draconian about this.
We'll just drive it out of the country.
It's already to some extent,
although the ICO that are happening are happening out of Switzerland or
Gibraltar,
um,
those teams are leaving the u s actually cause especially a place like New York
has been a very heavy handed in their regulations.
Um,
so you're just driving out innovation.
What is the incentive for,
Say New York to be supportive or at least maybe cast a blind eye to development
of this type of tech?
Well,
it's just like the Internet took out Hollywood with Netflix and uh,
you know,
um,
uh,
Spotify and it took out newspapers with publishing and Twitter and Facebook.
Um,
and it's taken out,
uh,
you know,
all kinds of industries.
Um,
the Internet is going to fundamentally change and possibly take out the finance
industry as we know it.
And the new finance industry is going to settle wherever the home of innovation
is for smart contracts and crypto currency.
This is my belief,
obviously not investment advice,
but um,
I think this is Silicon Valley's replacement of a lot of the infrastructure of
finance.
And so if New York chooses to drive that out,
then New York will no longer be the center of finance.
Got It.
I,
every time I go to New York,
I'm actually highly entertained because I see all these huge powers.
I see all these people in suits and I know that 90% of them will be obsolete
within 20 years.
Nice horse and buggy pal.
Yeah,
I would,
I would not be thinking about going into investment banking right now because a
lot of that job is going to be automated.
Commercial Banking,
automated,
you know,
the bankers were the miners of the last generation.
They got paid in the currency to secure the currency.
So when the Fed wants to,
they weren't even the minors.
So the traders,
yeah.
Well the Fed wants to distribute currency to give it to the banks and guess
what?
The banks,
the banks have sticky fingers and then the allocated out to the rest of us very
sparingly.
Um,
and the new bankers are the miners.
The new fed is the cryptographers,
but really the new owners of the infrastructure or the holders of the coin,
which is everybody,
or could be everybody
is cryptocurrency or let's say bitcoin inversely correlated to any particular
other asset classes.
For instance,
when people are fearful of say,
currency devaluation,
they've,
they might run to gold,
right?
It's seen this in places like Argentina is seen in the u s seed all over it.
Do you see that also with Bitcoin in a particular pattern?
Yeah,
they,
they definitely are a store of value because bitcoin,
there's only gonna be 21 million ever.
The whole way the protocol is designed.
You can't create a single one more and a bunch of been lost.
So,
you know,
cause they're hard to secure.
Uh,
hold on.
They get lost.
Well,
you could lose your keys.
So you call ice saying,
come up with something.
Really keep forgetting your Goddamn,
or you're trying to defend it.
You're trying to hide it from hackers.
So you come up with some really elaborate scheme and how to secure it and then
you lose it.
Or people that have lost the computer that it was on.
You know?
So there's,
have you heard any catastrophic story?
I'm sure there's stories of people with like,
you know,
digging through a garbage dumps with bulldozers,
trying to find that old computer which they threw out,
which had,
you know,
10,000 bitcoin on it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
You need,
you need to get a hardware wallets.
It makes encrypted backups so that you're neither were stolen from nor lose lose
your game.
Yeah.
So I mean there's a finite number of bitcoins.
So I a Bitcoin,
it's electronic gold.
There is a generation of kids who will grow up that as long as they have been
alive like my son,
when he's older,
as long as he's been alive,
there will have been gold and they will have been bitcoins.
You think the likelihood of Bitcoin in any way falling out of reach for people
like your son is close to zero?
I don't,
I think bitcoin itself may suffer because it has governance issues.
Uh,
and another currency like we should talk about a theory of,
and some of the others that are coming up might take its place,
but the idea that blockchain computers are going to go away is ridiculous.
That's like saying the Internet's going to go away.
Uh,
it's just too fundamental of a technology,
a barring a total mathematical breakthrough that obsoletes all encryption,
which would also be the end of the commercial internet as we know it.
Uh,
I think that's some kind of blockchain computer will dominate currency,
store of value,
contract law,
uh,
and any kind of financial instrument prediction markets,
all kinds of things,
uh,
in the future.
So to Mike,
to my kids,
they will choose electronic gold.
They will choose a bit cold and its successors over real gold.
Nick,
what is,
this is another one of these words that comes up at dinner parties and various
conversations and I kind of nod along,
some embarrassed to ask questions fearing I'm the only one at the party,
kind of like everybody goes to summer camp and they all missed their mom but no
one wants to talk about it and admit,
uh,
ethereum,
what is a theorem?
So,
so we talked about the blockchain computer.
So bitcoin,
I don't know if your audience can Harken back to the beginning of Apple Apple
Computer where Steve Wasniak was working at Hewlett Packard on a scientific
calculator and it had a certain limited scripting language that you know,
specialized for a,
that it wasn't a full fledged general purpose language that you can do lots
with.
But what he did was he got excited that his circuitry,
you know,
chips were getting cheap enough that you could do the full fledged what they
call turning machine after Alan Turing.
Cause he's one of the inventors of it.
I'm a full fledge general purpose,
um,
machine that can do any mathematically feasible computation.
And so bitcoin is like a restricted computer.
It does certain things specialized like the multisig I talked about and certain
other other things that can do,
but if they're IOM is,
is a much more general purpose computer and it also stores longterm state
better,
which is a,
it's a technical thing,
but it's an an important difference.
So basically,
um,
a theory has great potential for this reason.
It has potential to do smart contracts.
I'm much better than bitcoin does.
The drawback going to this is it also increases the attack surface.
It if witness ethereum is doing is riskier,
the attack attack surface.
So you can think of of your house is having a tax surfacers windows and doors
and places where people can get in,
right?
Well the ethereum thing has more surfaces that people could potentially get in
because people are doing
more things.
Got It.
Just more vulnerabilities that correlate to more functionality.
Right.
So I'm much more flexible computer so you can talk to it in many,
many more ways.
So you can inject bad code in,
you can hack it and many,
many models.
And another thing that it makes it risky is that a,
it's newer,
it's,
um,
not much more advanced than where in terms of its maturity and getting out all
the bugs and stuff as a bitcoin was when people were paying 10,000 bitcoin for a
pizza.
And yet what's the three market
cap now?
I think it just cross like eight or 9 billion today.
Marty caps are fuzzy because if you calculate a properly,
based on the future issues of the coin,
it might actually be approaching bitcoin's market cap.
It might be in the 20 billion range once you take inflation into account.
Anyway,
even with just the 10 million south,
there are eight billions out there now.
That's,
that's a lot more money than bitcoin had at the same stage of maturity.
So I definitely say it's at a riskier state.
It's also a much greater potential.
Yeah,
I mean,
this is so not what we can,
I think we've done a lot of backgrounding uh,
and I think what people really want to hear from nick about his,
a little bit more of the advanced stuff,
right?
Because you didn't bid Colita smart contracts.
So they kind of want to know where you think the future is headed.
And I know the feature is impossible to predict and against not investment
advice,
but ray generically,
what platforms are you most excited about?
Where would you spend your time if you were like a young fresh person walking
into this space?
So I am excited about um,
a theory m and a theorem classic and there's a,
what's called a side chain for bitcoin called rootstock that they hope to a
combined together,
um,
the best of a theory them with,
with bitcoin on the chain.
So you can trade the bitcoin currency but do the touring complete full fledge,
smart contracts.
The potential there is that and there very well could be other attorney.
I mean there's a few other touring complete ones out there and probably quite a
bit more in the works,
um,
as well.
Anyway,
the potential for this stuff is that doing cross border things and other things
were you're crossing a trust boundary and you don't necessarily have access to,
I'm good legal,
legal counsel,
affordable legal counsel for financial contracts.
Especially as the low hanging fruit because those are usually very well defined
and a bureaucrats like to make complications in that all sorts of epicycles to
them.
But really an option in the future and stuff.
They're,
they're logically and temporarily pretty simple things to do.
And once you get more than the underlying assets,
you can do options and futures.
You know,
as for example,
exchanging bitcoin for a threesome and we were getting all these other tokens
that are going to be on these blockchains,
you'll be able to include in that.
Now if you go off block chain,
you've got to kind of take a different tack.
The words,
if you're connecting your smart contract to the real world,
you need to,
you need to know what happened in the real world and decide whether or not
texted cute.
You're smart,
right?
So if you're doing an apple stock for example,
um,
cause that's,
that's a traditionally defined thing that depends on traditional systems to make
it work.
Incentivize apple to pay the dividends and,
and do what they do.
In any case,
if you want to do that,
then all of a sudden you're back in the traditional financial world and the
traditional financial people know that right now there's like a,
a,
a cultural disconnect that bitcoin people have a really cool technology and,
but they hate the people in the financial community and don't want to talk to
him,
don't want to learn from them.
And the same to some extent with these Syrian people as well.
And on the other hand,
the financial community,
people hate and don't understand blockchain and currency.
In fact,
there was this whole bunch of very dubious startups that raised a bunch of money
to do things they call blockchains that were,
they didn't have blocks,
they didn't have changed.
They weren't,
didn't have the security that I was talking about,
but the marketing people wanted to call them blockchains.
They could pretend to be like bitcoin and you know,
the price is going way up.
$15 million in financing later.
Yeah.
At the end,
these,
like most of the private blockchain company,
I'm not going to name names,
but yeah.
Yeah.
So the,
the financial people don't understand that and they've gotten burned by some of
these companies.
So they hate,
they hate it.
But what really I think for the entrepreneurial opportunity and some of your
listeners want,
are looking for non for an opportunity is to marry these two.
So pick the best of traditional finance,
take the best of the blockchains.
Um,
ethereum,
if you're doing sophisticated,
smart contracts and willing to take some risks and bitcoin if you're main thing
is,
is um,
cross border payments,
take these in and marry them together.
Figuring out ways to securely reflect assets on the blockchain using both
traditional financial controls and bureaucracy and taking advantage of
technology.
I think that's the,
that's the opportunity people haven't done yet because of this cultural
disconnect.
What would you say are some of the most important or valuable components of the
traditional finance world?
Like where would you start?
The traditional paperworld was really good.
It had a thing called separation of duties where,
um,
as we've talked about multiple people signing off on things and looking things
and you have to go through multiple stages.
Like,
if you get an order,
the salesperson has to give the order to the accounting department and they have
to give the order to the manufacturing people and everybody records it.
So it's like a little mini,
mini paper blockchain that,
that people used to have with computers that's Kinda gotten messed up.
And hackers can,
who know what they're doing,
can take advantage that these systems don't work as well now.
But,
um,
if you,
to a great extent,
you can make them work and people do make them work,
you know,
with a stock clearing and settlement and issuance and so forth.
So anyway,
yeah,
there,
there are experts in the financial community not to do that.
And if you can,
if you can make them love instead of hate blockchains,
then you'll have a great,
great skillset combination.
If you can get the blockchain and those guys together.
Yeah.
You're,
you're an interesting one because you combine law and computer science to do
unusual things.
And you're basically saying is you can combine traditional finance and now
computer science,
you do unusual things and write somewhere in that intersection is set.
You can take a,
uh,
a process that's entirely paper and move the part of it that belongs in the
blockchain on the blockchain.
Well,
plugging in the paper part
or,
or it used to be paper and somebody just naive Lee ported it in some naive and
secure fashion to computers and now you can use blockchains to make it much more
secure and trust minimized.
Yeah.
On the side of educating oneself,
so let's say there are people,
and I'm sure there are listening,
are part of the,
the traditional finance world who say,
that sounds like a great idea.
I want to learn how to love bitcoin and cryptocurrency.
I want to learn about this.
How would you suggest they choose reliable sources of information?
Because as we've noted before,
it's a bit of the wild,
wild west in some respects.
I mean,
you don't have,
not everyone is making disclosures about what they're,
their own portfolio might look like.
So there are,
there are a lot of to Barbara's telling you,
should you,
you should get a haircut.
And how would you suggest people think about that?
I mean if,
if you're technical and want to dive into the engineering and the technology of
it,
um,
the bitcoin white paper is,
is still by far the best place to start.
And Vitalik Buterin is a theory whitepaper also.
What was that name again?
Vitalik Buterin.
He's the guy who created it.
He's a lead developer on ethereum.
Uh,
he's actually an interesting guy,
young prodigy,
probably like 20 or 21 now.
Started it when he was 18.
Um,
absolutely brilliant.
There's a guy named Aviv Zohara was written some great papers.
One of them is on ghost,
which is what a third of them is based on.
Um,
and he's got a follow up to that whose name escapes me.
And he's also written a cough and a great paper on a tax against bitcoin from
the underlying network.
So he's one of the experts on the security of Bitcoin,
which is a skill and knowledge
and scare supplies.
Yeah.
One of the,
one of the problems and opportunities here is that,
uh,
you know,
going back to that earlier thing,
it's about money being the bubble that never pops.
Uh,
bitcoin is kind of a Ponzi seen scheme that starts with smart people.
So the smartest people understand it first,
then they sell it to like the people who need the cryptography explained to them
like me,
and then we sell it to the people who need the next level down and the whole
thing could pop in and badly.
So I'm not saying go put all your money in bitcoin.
Uh,
but I think to understand blockchain computer use,
you sort of have to get into the math and the code and the heart stuff.
But if you wait to figure it out,
by the time everyone can figure it out with the same tools,
it'll kind of be too late from an investment or earning perspective
from an investment perspective,
but not from a,
from the utilization standpoint.
No,
of course you'll be able to use money just as we use dollars,
but you're not going to be investing in something that is going to hockey stick.
Yeah.
The challenge for the industry is like today,
bitcoin has all these advantages that were gold.
You know,
it's,
it's more,
uh,
easily transmissible.
It's more sub divisible.
It's more easily stored.
It can be community by computers.
But to the average person,
that means nothing.
All they need to,
what they need to experience that they need to receive some bitcoin in a
transaction and then send some bitcoin transaction,
had the experience be so much better than every other experience they've had
with money or with gold.
And the tools just aren't there yet.
Like right now,
securing your bitcoin for yourself is still difficult.
The hardware wallets are getting better,
but it's still kind of a nightmare.
So I think the industry still has a decade of work to do to make
cryptocurrencies live up to their potential.
Uh,
and the idea space is so large and then all these companies working on it,
but every year it gets a little easier to use.
It has a few more use cases.
It gets a little easier to store.
Um,
and,
and the smart contracts that are built on it become a little more interesting.
Um,
so that is a process and eventually you'll be able to use bitcoin without
knowing anything about it.
Just like you can use US dollars without knowing how the federal open reserve,
open market committee works and you know,
does lending and issues,
treasury bills and all that stuff.
There's only a few geeks we need to know that in the world of finance,
uh,
and you can just use money like it's money.
Just to clarify one thing he said,
he said money is the bubble that never pops.
You're talking about the concept of money.
Yeah.
The concept of mine because individual currencies certainly.
Sure.
If tomorrow lived in Argentina between two thousand two thousand.
Yeah.
If tomorrow we all believe that the u s dollars is a green piece of paper and I
can't eat it,
I can't do anything with it.
Or if like aliens came and took over the world and you know,
we offered them a little green pieces of paper,
but just using it to start a bonfire or something.
Right?
So it's the money,
it's just a concept and we have to agree on what that scarce element is.
And today that scarcity is enforced by governments with guns and central banks
and it just breaks down and national borders and the people who secure that
money for you take a huge tax,
roughly a third of the economy in exchange for it.
Uh,
and eventually it will be a distributed network of computers,
um,
acting in self interest,
who are going to secure that,
the scarcity of that money and hopefully their tax is going to be a lot lower.
What else would a,
you're obviously much more on the pulse of this,
but what other topics?
It could be beyond my pay grade.
It probably is,
but should we
explore with,
with nick?
Yeah,
I think,
uh,
you know,
just talking about blockchains in general.
So we started with Bitcoin,
the blockchain,
which is around transferring money.
There's a etherium blockchain,
uh,
and others like it,
which are about computation and running like a very slow but very,
uh,
trust,
minimize reliable contracts.
Um,
what other uses can you see for blockchains coming up that you think maybe a
little farfetched,
maybe 10 years out,
but what's,
you know,
what's the possibility space?
Well,
I mean,
one of the possibilities is that I'm really excited about the cross border thing
to have,
say grandmother is in India and uh,
teenagers
in somebody's basement in Indiana doing what people north formerly thought were
sophisticated financial contracts such as options,
futures and Cetera,
you know,
through this online vending machine in the cloud.
That's the blockchain.
So that,
that's an exciting and probably to many people disturbing possibility,
um,
that I think is going to be coming up in the next 10 to 20 years.
Yeah.
I mean,
so you could have like people loading each other money or creating credit
instruments or engaging in prediction markets and things like that.
Yeah.
What do you mean by prediction markets?
Well,
I'll,
I'll talk about one that I,
that the insurance people are working on,
which is related,
which is,
um,
parametric contracts.
So normally an insurance will pay out,
you know,
if you get damages from a flood and they have to come estimate your damages,
which is basically a,
a wet human exercise and eyeballing how moldier wall is and how much you got
flooded and stuff.
But a,
an a,
a dryer way to do this is called parametric contracts,
where like if you're a hotel and in an area got hit by hurricane,
you can measure how much business he lost on your accounting books and,
um,
you can parameterize that and basically have your smart contract pay off if your
books go below a certain time or pay you more is the fog your books go down.
So that ensures kind of what you really want to ensure they hotel really wanted
ensure which is their business.
And uh,
it's also dryer.
It can be done by software verifying,
you know,
what the books are.
So you can make a smart contract out of that.
And there are other parameterized contracts as well based on other things that
computers consents and measure.
Yeah.
In prediction markets are,
you know,
people can actually make predictions and get paid if their predictions are
correct or lose money if their predictions are wrong.
And then these prediction markets can also serve as a arbitrators of truth and
pricing,
um,
into the smart contracts.
Um,
so for example,
uh,
you know,
[inaudible] Nick's case,
Nick's example,
the Ho you tie in directly to the hotels,
books,
the hotels,
the lost revenue.
And so you know,
whether or not to pay the hotel,
but if there's a flood,
I want to say,
was the hotel in the effected area,
was the hotel itself effected?
You need now what's called an oracle.
You need someone who's basically going to go in there and say like,
yes,
this happened.
No,
they didn't.
And prediction markets through very sophisticated engineering,
which I think is beyond the scope of this conversation.
Basically try and pay that person for telling the truth in a reliable way.
Uh,
and so you can use that to,
to cross the divide between the wet space and dry space or from the real world
into computers to have them do these things.
You can see,
you can see the insurance markets being completely overhauled by blockchain
computers and insurance.
A huge industry.
It's gigantic.
A lot of it just belongs in the blockchain.
I don't think you're going to have like a,
you know,
bankers in Bermuda,
uh,
doing this 20 years from now.
You do not think,
I don't think.
Yeah.
Because of the technical barriers to understanding,
uh,
or challenges,
let's say lead.
I think the,
to
be susceptible to say charlatans for very smart who can fool people who don't
understand technical aspects is a lot of scams in the space.
How do you,
what are the characteristics of charlatans or scams in the space?
Yeah,
it used to be easier to spot the louder they talked the scammy or they were,
now I think it's the scammers have gotten really sophisticated.
Some of these scammers are like version five of their scam.
So there'll be selling some coin and there'll be talking about how it enables
some functionality when reality,
the code doesn't,
or they have some back door where they're selling you a scarce coin,
but they can print a lot of them.
So in that sense,
you know,
there's,
there's a couple of coins that are sort of in the top set that are regarded as
top flight,
then it'll legit.
But what are those?
A big coin,
a theory.
I'm a kind of the best known ones.
Then there's sort of a second tier contender list of uh,
uh,
you know,
z cash,
Minero,
uh,
light coin,
etc. You know,
there's some new ones coming up like tasers,
these seem more legit,
but you,
you have to know your stuff and do your homework.
It's not something where I would recommend you just run out and buy.
Um,
and then there's a long tail of coins where there's a diamond in the rough here
or there.
Uh,
but there's a lot of junk too.
What's attracting people is just how much money you can make in this space.
You know,
bitcoin has basically doubled in value every year since its founding.
It's a,
it's,
and you know,
you do that for eight,
10 years and you end up with a very,
very steep curve.
Um,
something like etherium,
if you bought it when it was sold in the original presale today,
and just a few years later,
you'd be sitting on hundreds and hundreds of times your money and you'd be fully
liquid.
Um,
but this is not unrecognized.
The space has increased in value so much.
The market cap of all the cryptocurrencies is more than double just in the last
quarter.
So there's a lot of hot money flowing in.
Um,
well the flow back out possibly.
Are we in a bubble?
The environment,
probably a will this bubble pop,
nobody knows what pop across the board or will it pops selectively?
Yep.
Or will it pop later than a different pop?
So it won't matter because they'll be a flight of money from one asset class
too.
Exactly.
Or will the value switched from bitcoin to ethereum?
Will bitcoin fork into two competing coins because people are arguing over
whether the block size should be increased or not.
There's so much craziness just to,
just to pause on that word,
because this,
when I was attempting to educate myself and doing a pretty mediocre job of it,
this word fork came up over and over again.
And so in my mind,
I'm envisioning someone reading a lot about the,
uh,
so the making of the modern world and Genghis Khan and all this stuff.
[inaudible] and anyway,
thanks Dan.
Carlin for the hardcore history,
uh,
you would always,
you would have these internal factions that would then split off as two or more
separate groups in this context of what is for coming and how should,
how should I think about it in a coherent way?
This,
this is open source code.
So I can take your bitcoin,
I can create a copy tomorrow and it can change this at all the benefits go to
Nepal and,
right.
And that's a fork of Bitcoin that I'll call Navarro coin.
Now,
in reality,
people hopefully do more interesting forks.
So there's a fork of bitcoin called light coin,
which used the different mining algorithm in a different way to authenticate the
minors.
There's another four for call z cash,
uh,
which uses different privacy routines to basically allow for private
transactions.
So other people can't look in the ledger and know who,
who spoke to who.
Got It.
So not every node has full ledger.
Correct?
Well,
and every note of the full ledger,
but it's cryptographically,
uh,
hidden.
So you can't tell who sent who,
how much money?
No,
no.
In the forks.
So you just talked about,
um,
a z cash and light coin.
They started over from scratch.
They,
they started their own transaction history from scratch.
There's another more troublesome kind of fork where you don't start from
scratch,
you're just upgrading the current software with the same transact,
with the ongoing transaction history and you're trying to convince people to
follow.
And it's become a very political,
political process to be fighting over the people to,
uh,
to,
and,
and since,
you know,
bitcoin has,
the,
uh,
20 plus billion billion dollar value,
um,
you know,
people would much rather put their favorite idea into bitcoin,
then go off and start their own cryptocurrency from scratch.
It's like bitcoin only better.
Yeah.
And so there's,
there's tremendous political fights over,
over upgrades,
um,
in this space and just those were,
the bad blood comes in.
There's a huge debate right now in the bitcoin world,
uh,
where they're fighting over.
Um,
and,
and the basic,
the question is,
do you increase the size of the ledger?
Um,
it's,
it's the block size debate.
Do you increase the size of the blocks to hold more transactions so then you can
bring down the cost of each transaction so that I can go and buy coffee in
Bitcoin or do you leave bitcoin alone and treat it more as like a Swiss bank
where you only move around money,
rarely in large quantities and the smaller transactions are done on another
layer on top where you create another software layer on top,
they call it like lightening network as an example of that layer that which can
be used for very small,
very fast transactions and micropayments or not even micro,
but even like paying $5 for,
you know,
at Starbucks because bitcoin literally every time you do a transaction,
there are thousands and tens of thousands of computers all over the world that
are recording that,
replicating that and store it in there for all the time.
Right.
That's a lot of work.
Whereas you could probably run all of visas co computational power on a single
iPad today.
Um,
but as much as central as systems are much more efficient,
but they're much less secure,
that's kind of the trade off.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
this,
yeah,
I mean the first choice isn't for the blockchain itself really a viable choice
in terms of scaling is it scales from,
you know,
10 times the value of transactions value per second of transactions is today.
Um,
because the,
the,
um,
capacity's limited,
it does these full nodes that are running that requires certain bandwidth.
They have to talk to a lot of people,
make a lot of copies to replicate the stuff around.
And so there's a second layer and all was talking about that really the people
buying the coffee are going have to transition to,
and this has caused a lot of friction because,
um,
people are going to have to transition for the small everyday purchases from
bitcoin that blockchain itself to this second layer and there's competing
designs for the second layer and so forth.
And so there's,
there's plenty of,
of things to cause political friction.
Yeah.
Going back to the money,
that definition,
that debate is,
is bitcoin really a store of value or is it a medium of exchange?
Uh,
and,
and so,
nick,
I know you don't want to get into the middle of the politics of it,
but just from pure computer science perspective,
like if you were designing,
you know,
if you're redesigning a bit gold today and you wanted to incorporate some of
these learnings,
where would you fall in on,
what'd you go for a larger blocks?
Would you go for a second layer?
Oh No,
I'd definitely go for a second layer.
I mean,
I designed bitcoin gold with two layers because,
and can you explain just,
I must have lost something.
Just what that second layer is one more time.
The first layer is the block chain itself.
The bitcoin we call the capital,
be blockchain doing the secure transactions and the ones you can do from
Albania,
Zimbabwe without a trusted third party going through the blockchain and the
second layer and the ability to grow the transactions per second on that is very
limited.
Um,
you can grow the value per transaction quite substantially,
but the ability to grow a transaction for a second is limited because those have
a certain size and you have to make copies of them around
and so forth.
I see.
So the second layer would be for the coffee.
The pizza.
Yeah.
And so as this grows,
there's more and more people start using this.
They're competing for that,
that limited block space and the fees are going up.
And so if you want to have a cup of coffee without having to pay as much fees,
you paid for the coffee,
you know,
in two or three or four years from now,
um,
you're going to have to use one of these side chain,
what I call peripheral financial network,
that it's collateralized on the blockchain.
It's almost trust as trust,
minimized as the blockchain itself,
but it's for lower value transactions.
It only
periodically settle on the blockchain.
We talked a little bit about the,
I suppose,
third party tools,
so the application layer,
uh,
exchanges and so on,
the user experience being suboptimal currently.
But what if you could wave a magic wand and make certain things happen?
Make certain people invest in,
say,
Bitcoin,
what is,
what would be required to help bitcoin cross the chasm to be become much more
mainstream?
Maybe it's just inevitable and it's a matter of time.
That could be it.
But if you want it to accelerate the process,
and it was like,
okay,
we,
you can make wave a magic wand and you can choose any group of people to invest,
say $10 billion into bitcoin or whatever the number is and then fix x,
y,
and z that would help mass adoption.
And the crossing the chasm.
What are the things that come to mind?
Well,
I mean,
currencies have traditionally been associated with governments because
especially in the modern times,
they're the largest creditor and the largest debtor.
And so there they have the plurality of the,
and what is the,
you know,
the,
uh,
the money other people are going to use.
Um,
so right now bitcoin is being used for a snitch purposes where the Fiat system,
which,
um,
is a very weird,
like all permission system.
So blacklists people,
I've met people at bitcoin conferences,
um,
they've got plenty of money and stuff,
but they've been blacklisted.
They can't open bank accounts,
um,
and so forth.
So there's actually the heart,
the hardest thing.
So no,
not necessarily.
It could be just there,
you know,
they're suspected of something or um,
the money laundering laws are such that,
you know,
if somebody does something that looks suspicious,
you have to block it.
And so there's a lot of series of that kind of very erroneous error prone
permissioning that goes on with,
uh,
the bank system that doesn't go on with bitcoin.
Yeah.
Or pay file.
I was just thinking of friend from New Zealand for a host of,
so coincidentally,
factors just had a huge,
huge nightmare in his hand.
It took them months to resolve.
Yeah.
The way I participate in a cryptocurrency investing these days,
cause I don't want to have to worry about how do you procure it,
how do you secure it?
Uh,
oh,
even what to buy is I invest in hedge funds in this space.
Uh,
and I've actually joined when loosely as a venture partner.
Um,
and the biggest problem they have is getting bank accounts because the
regulators just digging too much.
If you're sending money in and out of Bitcoin or a theory makes changes,
um,
it's just something they haven't seen and they don't want to deal with it
because banks don't,
they don't have a system to charge you more for new weird stuff.
Um,
so just plugging into the existing banking infrastructure is hard and that's
probably where if their comp,
if countries do crackdowns,
um,
it will probably happen in that area.
So how do you fix it?
Or if,
if you had close to infinite resources and could just make certain things happen
too.
Yeah.
Facilitate good things or prevent bad things.
Yeah,
I mean,
first,
uh,
I would plug them into the existing banking system in a much better way.
They,
the existing banks,
you know,
should accept that if there's a legitimate player here,
they're only working with currencies that aren't scams.
Maybe they have some,
you know,
bonded collateral or something like that and they're legit actors.
Um,
they should be part of the banking system because this is the future of the
banking sector.
Must be banks because banks,
there are all shapes and sizes exist.
They do exist.
It's just they're much harder to find that you would think.
Um,
so,
and they're more Romania down the street from 20 western unions and they're
warming up to it.
The forward looking ones are warming up to it,
but we're talking about going from like one bank in the country to like 10 banks
in the country,
you know,
or five.
So it's still not a large set.
And these are small banks generally.
I feel like Singapore should get on that test case.
This is why some of these companies are going to Singapore actually.
And actually the,
the,
the worrying trend that I'm seeing is a lot of the more interesting development
teams and companies are all locating overseas.
Yeah.
Fleeing or receives.
One thing is that bitcoin and the other cryptocurrencies,
they operate under such different in the banking system that people in the
banking system and they look at,
you know,
these debates about block size and the people calling each other names and the
basically low level of trust that exists because it can't exist in the bitcoin
community.
Um,
and there were horrified because he couldn't run a bank that way.
You have to,
you have to be much more polite and careful and because they're wet word,
right,
right.
Because it's a wet social system rather than based primarily on dry computer
science.
Yeah,
you have it.
So you have a system here that allows anonymous trolls to engage in complex
financial transactions so they can,
they can scream at each other in college to the names while still doing
business.
Exactly.
That's the power of this system.
But it looks,
it looks horrific.
They don't know what else
the outside,
and that's why you have this cultural gap is because people in the banking
system looking at this and go,
oh,
this is,
this is terrible.
Can't possibly work
to,
to actually answer your question as to like what infrastructure needs to exist
to make this space happen.
Security is a big issue.
I think your average person today,
if they buy coin,
they don't know how to deal with what's called custody,
which is just how do you hold onto it in a way that if you,
if you don't go overboard in security,
you get hacked.
And if you go overboard and security,
you're going to forget your password or lose the private,
the all those go through a garbage dump or your or your kids playing with the
computer and website your,
your wallet file and there's no way to get it back.
So I think the secure the custody has to be solved and as nick mentioned earlier
there their hardware wallets that are out there,
they're starting to get pretty good.
Um,
they're getting good at enough now that you know,
the sophisticated people can use them,
but eventually they'll have to get so good that the average person can just use
them without having to think too much.
Yeah.
One of the interesting things here is that Nick's blog is called an enumerated.
And I'm going to let him explain what that means.
Well,
yeah,
so the tagline is an endless variety of topics might,
it's going to come to an end someday,
but,
uh,
um,
I don't limit myself basically is what it means on the topic.
If I,
if I think of something,
it will probably be relevant somehow,
but it doesn't necessarily have to be.
So,
um,
I,
I don't want to
like peg myself as a certain into a certain subject matter basically is what it
means.
And so the things,
a larger point where nick doesn't pigeonhole himself in his interests or his
identity,
uh,
and so that allows them to be more free and explore a wide arrange of
intellectual topics.
And so that's why I really enjoyed reading the blog.
And so that gives me sort of the next set of questions,
which are all around just random things in your blogs that I've read are things
that I've heard you talk about,
um,
which may not necessarily relate to public bitcoin or blockchains.
Um,
now you were the first to really convincingly argue.
and this goes way back about why microtransactions and the Internet were much
less likely than people thought because when I was growing up on the Internet
and then late nineties,
everyone thought micro transactions were just around the corner.
What would be an example of a micro transaction?
It's like every time I hit a webpage with a,
with an article,
I pay 10 to read that webpage.
Or uh,
every time we'll listen to a song,
I pay a penny that listen to that song.
Hmm.
Well it goes to a distinction I made earlier.
The computational costs versus our mental costs and the computational cost.
We've gotten a lot cheaper and our brains still same size.
So when you're doing a transaction,
you're doing a,
a,
a thought in your brain about is it worth it?
And that thought itself is costly and it's this costly.
Now as it's ever been.
Um,
modular,
you know,
you get a few extra market prices and some more information,
but the,
the,
our brain is still the same size.
So,
um,
just because computer scientists,
we're thinking,
well,
because we've reduced the cost so much,
now we can do these really tiny,
tiny things.
Um,
because we can do things much tinier and a penny.
But the trouble is of our brains can't handle that.
Computers could,
but our brains can't.
So that's what the idea of mental transaction costs,
the mental burden.
Right?
And so there's a quote that I really enjoyed and I'm going to try to not take us
too off track,
but there is no track that's the good distraction.
This is Alfred North Whitehead.
So quote,
it is a profoundly erroneous truism repeated by all copy books and by eminent
people when they're making speeches that we should cultivate the habit of
thinking about what we're doing.
The precise opposite is the case civilization advances by extending the number
of important operations which we can perform without thinking about them.
And quote,
is this applied elsewhere in your life
outside of blockchain?
Thinking about code and so on.
I mean,
do you,
are there ways that you minimize cognitive burden and other ways in your life
minimize cognitive burden
making these small decisions sort of cognitive microtransactions
yeah,
I would have to think about that for other things.
I know what I was thinking there also.
That's a,
he was being quoted by Fredrick Hayak who was talking about um,
how knowledge is distributed and markets.
And so markets have traditionally been a tool where we can communicate what we
want and how much we have for it and stuff.
And that really economized were only accumulating,
you know,
are only using a few numbers instead of,
going on and on about what we want and how much we need and how much we did
more,
deserve it more than the other guy and so forth.
So that right there,
it's a tool of social scalability because it reduces what could be a long and
drawn out argument over,
you know,
to a,
to a few numbers.
That was as asking.
We obviously don't have to get into it because there may not be a ready answer.
But because I was,
I was with a friend,
very,
very successful investor,
close buddy of mine.
We were walking through the airport just having a conversation and he said,
no,
I've realized that I optimize now.
I used to optimize everything he said.
Now I happen to miss one or two things.
And for everything else it's just good enough.
I basically d optimize everything else and it's made me,
he in his mind incredibly more effective by actively d optimizing,
which,
uh,
which I find
interesting concept.
Yeah.
I mean,
you just can't focus on everything.
Like Charlie monger is a famously bad driver,
right?
He's a probably a menace on the road and it's a good,
he probably takes Uber now,
hopefully.
Um,
but what's the point of being a good driver today,
right?
Especially if you have some other scope in your life where you can add unique
value.
Yeah.
In fact,
so reading your blog,
there are all these other little gems that I've found,
uh,
that,
can we go back to word or a or a name origin for one second?
Sure.
Does an enumerated have anything to do with the ninth amendment of the United
States constitution.
It does relate to that too,
because under numerated rights,
meaning you know,
there's new things going to happen with technology and other unexpected things
in the future and you need to define rights about around those.
And so you don't want to limit yourself to just that old list of,
you know,
we have a right to a free printing press,
but we don't have a right to,
to speak freely,
you know,
on Facebook or Twitter or so forth.
And uh,
so you,
you,
uh,
have to adapt,
um,
old ideas for the future.
Yeah.
So basically just because the right is not explicitly listed there,
it doesn't mean you don't have it.
In fact,
all of the unincorporated rights you have by default,
and it's only the ones that are actually restricted are the ones that are
restricted.
And that's,
that's,
uh,
something that I think our government and constitution scholars of the day just
completely forget,
as shown by the whole surveillance debate.
I mean,
it shouldn't even be a debate.
There's no,
I mean,
the right to privacy is very clear and even if it's not explicitly spelled out
our phones or private,
uh,
and our computers are private and our conversations are private ways of
thinking,
you know,
the,
the process of thought itself is kind of interesting,
right?
After a while you get introspective enough and you're like,
how am I doing on my thinking itself?
And one of the things that we run into online a lot
is people jump on any little contradiction,
right?
If I say something on Twitter,
uh,
and if I said something different a year ago or maybe out of context and a
different conversation,
people will jump on me and say,
well,
that's not what you said.
And so,
and so it's like a big Gotcha.
Right?
So I think we have this false,
a consistency that we all try and throw up when the reality is we're always
changing our minds.
And you know,
I forget who said it was,
somebody said,
when the facts change,
I change my mind.
What do you do?
Right?
Um,
so I,
I've gotten,
I've gotten okay with this concept of contradicting myself.
Right?
What,
what Michelle said,
like I contradict myself very well then I contradict myself.
I invest,
I contain multitudes,
right?
So I've gotten used to that.
Uh,
but then I encountered a concept in your writing neck that I liked,
which is it,
which just called quantum thought.
I don't know if you even remember this.
Um,
do you,
do you remember what I'm talking you that comes from law school.
So lost
law school,
they teach a very different way of thinking and that you need to take,
um,
you know,
both the defendants and the plaintiff side of the issue,
both sides of the issue and run down the arguments as if each one of them is
true.
They contradict each other,
of course,
or at least the conclusions and,
and some of the sub arguments contradict each other.
And so I compare this to Schrodinger's cat.
Maybe it's alive,
maybe it's that,
maybe that defendant's guilty,
maybe,
maybe they're not.
And uh,
you have to keep both of these in your mind at once.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
this is not how we are socially taught to think socially.
We are taught,
you have to have a point of view.
You have to have an answer,
you have to pick a side,
pick your tribe,
fit in,
and then defend it and be consistent.
But,
uh,
the reality is really complicated.
And so if you're really smart and you're operating on the edge of any field or
trying to figure out anything new,
you probably need to have quantum thought.
You'd probably have to hold both states in your head and constantly weighing
probabilities.
And if you're not shifting back and forth,
then either you're not doing something cutting edge and you're not being
intellectually honest with yourself about.
So I've,
I've a question for you about this and I'll just start with just an anecdote,
which was,
uh,
I was at a friend's house recently and it was a gathering of 20 people or so.
And there was some structure to the weekend and people were broken out into
groups to have various discussions.
Everyone,
they're very intelligent,
normally highly rational and politics was the,
the topic of the day.
And it just devolved into acid spitting and craziness almost immediately with
the exception of one session in the reason that session was different is that
the moderator said before we get started,
I want to go around the room and everyone needs to pick one piece.
It could be a tiny piece of the opposite side,
the person they disagree with and just argue for its validity for even 60
seconds and go around the room and did that and it took 10 minutes and then
everyone was much more open minded and patient and productive in the
conversation.
So my question for you leading off of that is how have you trained yourself to
practice quantum thought or how would you recommend someone develop that because
it's not something that most folks think about.
Certainly something historically I didn't dedicate a lot of time thinking about.
I was always more concerned with defending whatever position I feel like
everyone else should be engaging in.
It would actually stick.
No.
Well I mean it's good.
It took,
you know,
quite a few loss takes a few law school tests to get used to us.
The one thing you can do is take the first year of law school and learn how to
do this,
but imagining that you're the other person certainly in going through their
arguments and you might even imagine it as a,
as a courtroom and you trade places,
you argue for one side and then the other,
so you even can think of it as a court room in your,
I think it might
help some people.
It seems like people who have either self selected by gravitating towards debate
or taken debate where they're forced to take opposite positions and Ken
arguments helpful as well.
Blasting Socrates.
Right.
And he would always,
he would always just keep digging and arguing the point a and you can never pin
him down on his beliefs because he was always exploring the thought space.
Well,
it's also,
I mean this practice just re people who were like,
I don't want to be open minded,
but okay,
they're not going to explicitly say that,
but if you want to be maximally persuasive,
you know,
Charles Darwin actually did this very,
very well and when I'm about to say in the origin of species is instead of Straw
Manning,
and I think Sam Harris is used this expression,
uh,
steel manning.
So in other words,
he would,
he would try to anticipate the objections that people would have and then he
would not take the sort of weak and flimsy version of their argument.
He would build it up and make it as compelling as possible before he would
counter it and his own,
you know,
writing.
That's the intellectual,
the honest way to do it,
which is this way.
It's also very,
very effective way.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause then you're actually,
uh,
then you're actually arguing on the real merits,
not on what you,
not on the anecdote.
You picked up a piece of it that you picked to attack.
So Neil Strauss' and eight time New York Times bestselling author,
he's been on the podcast,
but he said every time he edits his own work first yet it's for himself.
So he keeps the wants to keep it interesting and fun for himself.
Second,
again,
it's first fans,
make sure everything is clear and then he edits for his haters.
Hmm.
So that he can steal men and bulletproof things to the extent possible.
Twitter's taught me that.
I mean you have got 160 characters.
Everything you say at 140 most of the time everything you say will be taken out
of context and used to attack you.
Um,
so you really just have to boil it down.
You,
you have to,
you have to hone it.
Um,
and uh,
I tweet mainly because it helps me clarify my own thinking.
Yeah.
It's quite the exercise actually.
I think they,
the accidental limit from text messaging days turned out to be a huge bonus for,
for Twitter.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
so just kind of moving,
moving on a little bit there.
There are these other little phrases your coined that,
um,
helped me crystallize my own thoughts.
So there's a,
there's a class of things that people seem to worry a lot about these days,
whether it's an asteroid hitting the earth or um,
you know,
uh,
papa apocalyptic scenarios,
floods,
skynet,
Ai,
you know,
let's just say even like near term climate change predictions.
Like I think we're all supposed to be underwater by 2020 or something.
Right?
Um,
but there,
there is definitely a class of people who will take anything on the Internet and
blow it out of proportion.
And sometimes it can be a warning,
sometimes it can be good,
sometimes can be bad.
Like the general AI thing is another one of these.
And you summarize this whole class of,
um,
statements under what I thought was a brilliant,
uh,
little moniker,
Pascal scams and where does that come from?
So that comes from Pascal's wager.
Um,
and it can be applied to any,
any,
um,
claim that there's an infinite or very large reward or punishment,
or outcome of positive or negative nature.
And the argument goes that even if it's a very improbable because this,
this reward or outcome is so large,
you should pay attention to it.
Right?
And Pascal originally basically said,
you have to believe in God because just in case,
because if
God doesn't exist,
who cares?
I've got does exist.
And you don't believe.
Exactly.
So you should believe that was the argument.
The basic flaw in this kind of thing is there is an infinite number of,
of of infinite outcomes.
If you expand your space infinity,
there's,
there's an infinite number of things that can happen.
So you can't,
the odds of any one of them happening are infinitesimal,
right?
So you don't get a large expected value when you multiply infinite by
infinitesimal.
It's some undefined thing you can't really reason about.
But um,
but people do anyway.
But people try anyway.
So they say,
well,
even,
you know,
we,
so this precautionary principle kind of stuff and you can only take it so far.
And the other problem with improbable things he is,
there are error bars on the probability.
You don't know if it's,
you know,
one in a billion or one in quadrillions or something.
So right there that changes your expected value.
Many orders of magnitude and usually you know,
people are trying to get attention and so forth or you know,
they have a job that depends on I'm scaring you and they're trying to,
uh,
they're trying to make you believe the probability is higher.
Yeah.
It to use and the seem to labs language.
Uh,
and you should definitely get him on the podcast some point by the way,
that I can do that should happen.
I've had dinner with him a few times.
I think that would be highly entertaining.
I would,
oh yes.
I want a front row seat on that.
I guess it would be under it,
but it's used Tellabs language.
You know,
some Black Swan is likely to happen,
but any particular black swan is very unlikely to happen.
And so people are just trying to scare you with a particular black swan and
because it can end your world,
even in fantastical probability has to be taken seriously and you can waste your
entire life worrying about these things,
whether it's suitcase nukes or,
um,
you know,
another financial crisis or the world exploding or imploding or cooling off or
whatever.
Now just to,
just to touch back on the black swan though,
Naseem and I first met,
if you can imagine the circumstances the day that Lehman brothers officially
sort of imploded,
right?
Highly improbable.
At least if you're looking back,
sir,
a few years prior and he has done very,
very well financially by not betting on all black swans,
but betting on a few select black swans and bleeding in small chips for long
periods of time before occasionally having some type of windfall like that.
Right.
So in when you're considering
some of these improbable events,
how do you decide which to hedge by certain behaviors or not?
For instance,
in San Francisco,
the,
I've really went deep into training with the police department and Fire
Department for,
uh,
the disaster response.
Right.
Looking at the potential consequences of say,
a high magnitude earthquake and it's like,
okay,
it probably makes sense for me to spend 100 bucks on instacart and just get away
when reality trip on your stairwell and well no,
no that's more likely.
But the point I'm making is like most people have a fire extinguisher in the
kitchen that they will never use.
Right.
You wear your seat belt.
We've probably never been in a high impact collision.
So there are certain classes that are low cost,
very easy in terms of preventative.
So how do you think about,
how do you,
how do you personally think about it?
I mean,
but uh,
not erects not,
no,
that's not me.
I'm problem.
Something happens.
A lot of people not an asteroid and destroying the planet.
It's a probability thing.
Yeah.
Where,
where does it have the probability spectrum?
Is it,
uh,
if it's one out of 10,000,
you know,
you should probably worry about it or at least take basic precautions.
If it cool.
If it has never happened yet but could happen and would wipe out all of
humanity,
or like once a generation,
then it's sort of in the sphere where you just can't think about it or you'll
just go insane.
Well,
I take a first lot of people do go,
you know,
they do.
Some were crashing on a magnitude 10 quake in San Francisco.
It could happen,
the odds are low,
but it could happen.
Um,
you could keep that fire extinguisher round.
You could add somebody,
you could add some things,
but you know,
you're the building you're in,
it'll just collapse on you anyway.
Um,
well,
yeah,
I mean there's,
oh,
the,
the extreme example of this,
the one that,
uh,
you know,
a lot of people in our social circle are constantly pedaling is a singularity
example.
It's very seductive.
One,
you know,
even Elon Musk was otherwise absolutely brilliant.
It seems to be taken in by it.
And,
uh,
and you know,
I give him credit for,
for worrying about it and thinking it through and so on,
but it's just another one of these pascal scammed it seems like.
Can I come back to that just because I know we're going to,
that's a big worry about really [inaudible] with this.
A Hornet's nest.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's not full of candy.
I don't know.
It depends I guess and how you go about it.
But before we get there,
nick,
is there anything that you worry about that many other people don't worry about?
Things I worry about that many other people don't.
I don't know.
People worry about so many things,
but I mean,
people worry about privacy,
but that seems to be going the wrong direction anyway.
Um,
you talked about the singularity,
I heard somebody coined the phrase,
I forgot who it was.
Creepy polarity that we're slowly,
life is getting creepier and creepier is more strangers are appearing in on more
and more personal parts of our lives.
So I worry about that.
Got It.
I did do a podcast won't help.
Do you take,
do you take preventative,
any particular preventative measures that other people might find helpful?
I do,
but a lot of them are sub security through obscurity,
so I can't,
yeah.
A guy that understood.
Uh,
alright.
So singularity,
uh,
lead the way in of all right.
Well actually before we get into that,
I think the privacy issue is really interesting.
One because physical privacy is being utterly destroyed and I don't think people
realize the extent to which is going away because cameras are essentially
ubiquitous and face rec and um,
everyone can track everything except privacy is possible in one realm,
but it wasn't possible before it was digital privacy and that's encryption.
That's a story of blockchains and blockchain computers,
I'm blushing.
Computers can enable digital privacy to a level that you just couldn't get
otherwise.
Um,
so one of those sets of things we didn't talk about is things like z cash and
Monero and other blockchains that are all about privacy.
And if you want to touch on that at all,
yeah,
there are a couple.
Um,
so you can achieve,
because bitcoin doesn't require identity.
You can achieve some minimal amount of privacy.
But um,
once they track,
you know,
go to go to the,
again,
the Bitcoin Pheonix change,
they can tie the address to an identity.
I'm that way and a trace it back.
And there are some,
a minimal,
basically if you buy on an exchange,
they'll know what account that it,
the money was sent to or the coins were sent to.
And then every time the coins move,
someone can analyze the blockchain cause they have a copy too.
And they can say it went from account Exito count,
why account Y to z?
And they might lose track use somewhere along the way.
But,
uh,
I haven't heard someone say that law enforcement is starting to refer to
a big coin is prosecution futures.
Sometime in the future they will be able to unwind that who was doing be like a
analyzing Lance Armstrong's blood 10 years later.
Oh,
we do have that.
But we still have a copy and now the technology has gotten better.
Right?
Execution.
A guy named David [inaudible] invented mixes and applying and mixing and
blinding and applying this technique to money.
Um,
tour is a version,
applying it to communications,
but uh,
applying this to money.
So,
um,
you can do a little bit of,
I'm mixing or tumbling in Bitcoin,
but Minero you can do it quite a bit better.
And then z cash hasn't even more advanced.
Um,
privacy features.
Yeah.
Essentially the,
when they're,
uh,
and I don't want to,
the mineral community is very acidic,
then they fight the z cash communities.
So they get into battles with each other,
but they are different approaches.
One approach is I'm doing a transaction and there are five other people do a
transaction.
We all pull our transactions together.
And then so it's someone who's trying to analyze the blockchain.
We'll just see that five transactions were done and these are the five
participants.
But you've law,
they can't tell what,
when to whom.
And something like z cash takes it a step further and just the entire ledger is
opaque.
Like it's all cryptographically protected.
You can't tell who exchanged what.
And there are these crazy complicated proofs that go into proving who still has
what money.
Um,
and in theory,
z cash is much,
is very private.
It's sort of the extreme edge of privacy,
but it's computationally extremely expensive and it's brand new cryptography,
which hasn't yet withstood the test of time.
What makes a particular currency appreciate and value?
I know this is probably a stupid sounding question,
but I guess there's,
because on one hand you have [inaudible] these nuanced sort of technological
features,
right?
So if someone might focus or say as a particular currency,
my focus more on privacy and then another might focus more on x,
y,
and Z,
then you have supply and demand,
right?
If Kim Carr,
if Kim Kardashian gets up tomorrow morning and decides that she's read a lot
about bitcoin and wants to Instagram about it for the next 10 days straight,
I would imagine that would have an impact on prices.
I think you can look at a framework of,
you can say,
first of all,
is this doing something novel and useful?
Like is this useful?
Um,
is privacy useful?
Is Computation you useful?
Is exchanging money useful?
Then you can say,
is this the right technology solution?
Cause there's probably 20 other blockchains competing for it.
Then is it being adopted?
Is there a network effect to people have in their wallets?
Is the infrastructure exist?
Are they using it?
Uh,
and then supply and demand.
And that gets gamed a lot.
Sometimes the developers of these coins are pumping out more coins in the
background.
You don't know are they reserve the right and it read the source code to figure
it out.
So that's why investing in some of these extreme,
uh,
so called altcoins or app coins is very scary.
Um,
but there are other applications coming up that are really interesting.
So there's like a one coming out called file coin,
uh,
where I'm a small investor,
so disclaimer,
but there are others,
this storage storage and others,
I like that also that are basically trying to create a network of distributed
computers that will do storage for you.
So instead of uploading your files to Dropbox or Amazon,
you can upload massive files into these distributed storage and networks that
will take your data encrypted split across thousands of machines.
And then they'll test to make sure your file is still available,
the network if you ever need it back.
And then you'll pay people in the coin.
Um,
and so people who you don't know,
grandmothers in India might be holding a piece of your file and waiting to serve
it back to you when you need it,
uh,
as a backup or just for storage or serving.
Um,
and you'll be paying them fully anonymously and from far away and the whole
transaction is handled to the network.
Um,
there's another one called block stack,
which is building an infrastructure for the decentralized internet,
including domain names,
names,
serving,
uh,
done in a distributed fashion today.
All the name servers are controlled by ICANN and verisign and so on.
But what if you could split that out amongst the distributed network of
computers?
You could pay people in coin,
uh,
on the network for doing that.
So these kinds of applications are coming up and for each one of these you look
at like,
is it novel,
is it useful?
What's the competition?
Is a code secure?
Other developers,
scammers or their back doors was supply and demand.
So it's still completely wild west,
which is both the opportunity and the terror of it.
I mean the,
I think the average person who's investing in coins,
uh,
on most of them is probably going to lose their shirts over a long enough period
of time because the scammers are really sophisticated.
Uh,
but I think the really smart people who know what they're doing and maybe get a
little bit lucky,
you're going to make generational fortunes.
Nick,
what are your thoughts on singularity?
So,
well,
getting back to Pascal,
I was going,
I was going to try to do something clever with generations,
but I was like,
you know what,
I can do this.
A lot of the,
I,
I those are scams and Pascal scams are these big scams where like you can't
calculate the probabilities because you're dealing with affinities.
And the most recent of the Pascal scams is making the rounds is a singularity.
Yeah.
So the,
I mean,
the idea of the singularity,
they've seen this exponential growth in computer resources and the fact that
computers are outstripping humans.
And then they sort of impute from that,
that,
and you can also see computers take over,
um,
you know,
things that used to be considered a sign of intelligence to be able to add and
subtract quickly and now computers can do that and billions of times faster than
humans.
So,
and the gap keeps growing and growing.
Once you computer can do something,
the gaps just going to keep growing and growing.
But the idea of the singularity tends to be the,
you get a general intelligence,
like it at some point,
computers can do everything humans can do and all of a sudden,
you know,
very quickly they can do it faster and faster and faster.
They start designing improved versions of themselves and it's a runaway effect
and human soon become obsolete or pray for terminators and whatever we can't
predict.
And so one of the,
one of the,
uh,
conceits is the idea that,
oh well no longer be able to predict the future.
Um,
the thing is that's,
that's basically true today for a lot of things.
You can't,
you know,
the stock markets and ongoing running singularity,
you can't predict day to day if you could,
you could make a fortune.
So,
yeah,
you laid out a lot of arguments against it.
And another one is just what does this general intelligence thing like humans
are highly adaptive specialized machines and every other animal that's around
today,
including the cockroaches,
just as evolved as we are,
it's just different fitness functions.
And so it has a different concept of intelligence that it needs to survive.
And machine intelligence that we've developed so far to extremely specialized.
So there probably is no such thing as general intelligence a.
Instead,
what we have is machines that are brilliant at calculation but terrible at other
things and now they're getting brilliant or face recognition.
But that doesn't mean they're going to be really great at me solving my next
debate with my wife.
Right.
It's something else you touched on that,
uh,
I appreciated.
And as a non scientist,
none engineer who sometimes pretends to do such and physical performance and
whatnot,
uh,
quote there is as Fineman sets,
it's Richard Fiman.
Everybody should read a surely you're joking.
Mr. Simon.
But I digress.
There is this Fineman said quote plenty of room at the bottom end quote,
but it is by no means infinite given actual demonstrated physics.
That means all growth curves that look exponential,
more in the short run turn over and become s curves are similar in the long run
unless we discover physics that we do not now know as information and data
processing under physics as we know it are limited by the number of particles we
have access to.
And that in turn can only increase in the long run by at most a cubic
polynomial.
Uh,
and probably much less than that since spaces mostly empty.
It seems underlying this singularity is the assumption that exponential
continues
to be exponential indefinitely.
Right?
I mean we've had exponential growth for computers for most of the last century.
Yeah.
And so we have this vast resources that I've already talked about to take
advantage of,
but the future,
you're going to face these physics limits,
you know,
limits on the heat that you're circuits give out.
They turn into toasters,
um,
and,
and so forth.
So,
um,
yeah,
and it's the limit set by quantum mechanics and we're,
we've reached that in some,
I don't think Moore's law really applies to transistors necessarily anymore.
The original Moore's law is not the number of transistors.
I think that's already,
yeah,
there's a physical limits of how
far transistors and go.
Then there's a question about transistors,
even the right medium,
like maybe to exhibit our kind,
our variation of specialized intelligence.
It needs to be on wet where like it needs to be on tissue and we have not yet
gotten to growing brain tissue and then programming it.
That's a long ways off.
Um,
and then you have to deal with the fact that our brains evolve and our
intelligence evolves in reaction to our environment.
And even genetic algorithms evolve in reaction to fitness functions.
So you not only would you have to create a computer that could run on our tissue
to inhibit,
to exhibit our kind of intelligence,
but then you would also have to put it in our kind of environment and it's rid
of learning would be limited by what inputs are environment can provide,
right,
and if you're going to go do all that work,
then just have a baby takes nine months and we already know how to do anything
right time.
Well on that point related to environment,
this is a,
and you've written quite a bit on this,
but I underlined one portion quote,
so these evolutionary techniques and other machine learning techniques or are
often interesting and useful,
but the sun,
this severely limited ability of computers to simulate most real world phenomena
means that no runways in store,
just potentially much more incremental improvements,
which which will be much greater in Simi lable arenas and much smaller and
others and will slowly improve as the accuracy and completeness of our
simulations slowly improves.
Just to underscore what you just said,
you need access to the environment or the ability to create,
right.
There's also a probabilistic argument against general intelligence,
which is the universe is so vast and so large that if generally it's like it's
the same,
it's the same people who make the gentleman today's argument also make the we're
living in a simulation argument.
Well they kind of both can't be true because if we're living in a simulation,
uh,
then that means that at some point we already invented a general intelligence.
Like when you get the technological capability to invent a simulation of this
complexity,
um,
probabilistically and you believe general intelligence that possible it through
the mechanism described in the singularity,
then we probably already hit that along the way.
So that means that whatever that gentlemen AI is already exists and we're just
living inside it sim.
So why do we have to worry about it suddenly emerging here and then killing us
all?
Yeah.
So the people who are both holding the simulation hypothesis in their head and
the singularity being around the corner and their head are sort of at a deep
level contradicting themselves.
Particularly if,
I don't know,
I guess the,
so the simulation,
I wish we had Sam Harris here to talk about.
I don't know.
I've mentioned that somebody I was just talking about freewill.
He isn't it.
He's,
he's interesting to talk to you about that,
but the,
the idea that something would come to be that is a thousand,
a million times,
a billion times more generalizable.
He intelligent than we are and their priority would be killing us.
It's just like my,
my,
my directive in life,
being running around,
killing cockroaches,
no cockroaches.
I don't really care so much about them but it seems odd.
Yeah.
I think that movie her actually did it pretty well,
which is,
you know,
when the general AI evolves in that movie,
it just left.
Yeah.
He didn't care about this world at all.
Uh,
sooner vault,
you've,
you've mentioned a bunch of things you're not worried about.
I'm curious to ask you the same question as nick,
which is what are the things that occupy your mind more than perhaps other folks
are?
Many other people,
I try to keep it very low level of mental surface activity for anything other
than whatever I'm directly dealing with in the moment.
And one of the ways I'm trying to do that is by stripping away layers of
identity.
So I don't want to or they identify as Indian or American or libertarian or are
Democrat or any of those kinds of things because one that sort of keeps me from
actually engaging in thinking as I need to.
It's all preconceived beliefs.
It makes me more defensive because once you,
the reason you can't talk about politics that anybody's,
because it attacks our identity at the core level.
Every tweet I put out,
I now know that even if I attack a general class of activity,
all the people who are engaged in that activity will respond.
So like I put out a tweet about how you want to,
you know,
value investing in venture investing or both.
Longterm investing and trading is this get rich quick scheme,
which doesn't work.
And so of course,
all the people who've got really angry about that,
I guess clicked through to the bio.
And sure enough,
they're traders like that.
That's what they do.
They trade all the time and for Wall Street,
and that's how they make a living.
So if you attack someone's identity,
you're shut down all conversation with them.
That's why politics,
political conversations don't work.
So conversely,
if you want to be rational and open minded,
you should not have an identity.
And the less of an identity you can absorb can adopt the better.
How do you train yourself to identify less as Indian as excess?
Why?
Human consistency bias,
a powerful thing.
So just when someone asks you,
are you a libertarian?
Just say I'm not anything.
You know,
if they say like a religious,
you know that they don't say anything like look like Marty is one of my favorite
philosophers.
When he met the pope,
uh,
you know,
the,
the pope said to him like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm pope blah,
blah,
you know,
from this lineage and so on.
Who are you and Christian word?
He's just said,
I'm nobody.
Right?
But he was being serious.
Like I don't even know what I am.
I'm just this thing that's here right now in this environment,
reacting to the inputs from the environment according to my conditioning.
And I'm trying to be as unconditioned as possible,
but that's why my,
uh,
my Twitter,
um,
uh,
my Twitter Avatar is like a sketch of a human face because it's turning to
remind me to be unconditioned.
You don't want to be over conditioned and you don't want to be overly strong
with your identity.
You guys mentioned Twitter earlier,
so one of the things that you may have noticed,
I do this,
but I routinely put out things on Twitter and Facebook that I used to call my
audience of hypersensitive people or that I know will just kick the Hornet's
nest enough to force people to self select one way or the other.
Yeah.
And I have to be careful not to then accidentally create a group where they all
have sort of group health.
Yeah,
exactly.
Thank you.
Want to prune the trees in the forest for the trees?
A little bit.
But also what that does is,
uh,
it gives me more,
I fee,
I perceive having more freedom of speech or willingness to speak my mind because
I'm progressively,
uh,
creating less and less of a reputation to protect.
Yes.
And so that's right.
Yeah.
I do the exact same thing,
which is I would say every,
every couple of months,
my tweet stream gets a little edgier,
right.
As I've sort of pushed out the people who can't deal with what I'm saying,
uh,
and I've muted them or block them or just stay one followed me or what have you.
Um,
and I didn't used to block,
but now I've had to like,
it's just because there's always somebody who's Straw man,
whatever you're saying,
get outraged and to start a fire and assemble a mob around it to like burn you
at the state.
Uh,
and unfortunately it's a lot of the best people on Twitter have left because of
that issue.
Right?
Like p market probably being the most famous,
but uh,
you know,
you can put out a hundred tweets a day and you say one thing wrong and one of
them and they're trying to burn you at the stake.
It's always the most controversial ones of mine that get put on reddit and
spread beyond.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
P Marker for those interested.
That's Marc Andreesen.
I think this is a general phenomenon where society has not yet figured out how
to deal with social media.
I think like in my kids' generation,
there'll be saying all kinds of crazy things and Twitter and nobody will care.
Nobody will lose a job over it and nobody will get worked up over it.
Cause everyone was saying everything crazy all the time.
But right now,
and we were transitioning from a world of our thoughts being private to our
thoughts,
being public.
People are still getting outraged.
But to me like the people who get outraged or sort of the most anachronistic,
least intelligent members of society and I'm happy to leave them behind.
The more easily outrage you are,
the less I want to have to do with you.
Be Gone.
So if you think words can hurt you,
you're going to live in a world of misery and pain your entire life.
So on that note,
I'd like to wrap up.
Just kidding.
Uh,
so,
so I want to gear shift for a second and ask a few questions,
uh,
of units that are not directly related to they might be,
they might edge into it but not directly related to a cryptocurrency.
Uh,
the first is if people want to explore your blog and you have some very
extensive writing and where might you suggest they start?
Is there a particular piece or a few pieces that might be a good diving in point
for people?
Yeah,
so for our blockchains and cryptocurrencies and smart contracts,
probably the two best ones.
Um,
money blockchains and social scalability is a recent blog post of mine.
And then in a somewhat older blog cope post called dawn of trustworthy
computing.
What are some of the subjects that you enjoy exploring outside of the ones that
we've already heard about in terms of the,
we understand the fascination with money,
currency law,
what are other interests that might not be immediately evident to people if
they're reading your blog?
Yeah,
and we also mentioned the origins of money origins that in big interest in
related interest of mine.
Um,
and history in general.
I read a lot of history.
Any particular I economic and legal history mostly.
Um,
so
are there any particular resources or books that you've enjoyed in that area?
Um,
so Alford Crosby's the Colombian exchange,
which is basically what Jared diamond ripped off when he
wrote his
Alfred Crosby wrote the original better version.
I know he just really,
Jared diamond for me,
it turns out he was this a popular,
yeah,
Jared diamond's a hypothesis on what happened on Easter island also turns out
that's right.
I'm probably not huge lapse.
Not that.
Yeah.
We all do.
We all make our mistakes.
The,
uh,
one of the questions I ask guests on the podcast oftentimes is what books have
you gifted the most other people?
And I don't know if you have any of that come to mind.
Um,
so Richard Dawkins,
the selfish gene is,
is sort of on my essential,
everybody should read this list.
Yeah,
definitely.
One of the classics.
All the doctrines is getting outraged on the Internet a lot these days.
He's,
he's good at the same kind of outrage.
Oh my God.
I saw a,
uh,
public speak public talk of his in the Los Angeles.
Not too long.
It was food's fantastic,
but I was just like every given second,
I'm like,
I wonder if this room is going to explode.
Not with outrage or applause,
like literally a,
any other books,
that kind of mind.
And I mean,
Matt release written several good books on,
on evolution,
social evolution,
and a couple of genetic evolution as well.
Do you spell his last name?
Matt.
Ridley.
Okay,
got it.
Yeah,
I think three or four of my top 20 books of all time are all read these rational
optimist genome red queen origins of virtue,
which is your favorite.
If you had to recommend one,
if you had to recommend one rational optimist and he has evolution of
everything,
which I haven't read yet.
If you were teaching a this fee you neck,
if you were teaching a,
let's call it a high school freshmen class or seminar,
could be on any topic,
what would you teach?
Well,
I just gave some lectures at my a honorary doctorate university.
I'm on related lectures on the origins of money and blockchains and
cryptocurrencies.
So to me those are three closely related topics that I like to and how they're
really for what period of time did he teach that class or was it an hour long
lecture?
So I tried to cram way too much into it.
What would you hope people would take from those lectures that they only
remembered two or three things?
Is there,
are there any core critical takeaways you would help them?
So money's not arbitrary.
If you look at the history,
origin of the money,
you see all sorts of different things,
textiles and Yap stones and this and that and so forth.
But indeed is not arbitrary.
Um,
they're very consistent.
things like unfortunately costliness the demand for scarce supply and the
durability,
people choosing durable objects.
Um,
so that,
that sort of realizing that by reading that is partly of what helped me figure
it out.
Yeah.
You could do this in cyberspace as well.
Um,
so what does in your,
in your life,
what does money buy you?
I know it may sound like an odd question in my life and yeah,
I'm not as much as one would have thought cause I,
I find myself,
I'm consuming time to do things that I,
I would,
I would like to substitute money for,
but can't I have to take the time to do them anyway.
So what,
what drives you to write as much as you do?
Well,
partly that's what I want to do it in life.
So you enjoy the process of,
I like the freedom of thought and stuff.
And so I'd much rather sit at home thinking of my own stuff and then,
you know,
thinking what my boss wants me to think.
Right.
What are things you'd like to write about that you haven't had a chance to
explore yet or that you have on deck?
Um,
so I've written some things about,
um,
the industrial revolution that I have some meetings,
thoughts on,
but I'm so busy with other things I'll probably never get to.
Um,
and on what I call the exploration explosion,
how,
how Europeans were able to go around the globe and,
and a takeover in the world's trade routes and so forth,
you know,
after Columbus.
So there's all sorts of those,
those are two of my favorites,
but there's,
there's plenty of others as well.
Never have time to do.
Can you,
can you give any teaser snippets or concepts from the industrial revolution?
Well,
I don't,
I don't know if this made it on the recording,
but the hourglass as mentioned earlier,
is an underrated intervention.
This humble glass thing with sand in it.
So Europe invented like the mechanical clock and which I think most of you will
recognize it as an important invention,
but they also at the same time,
and not coincidentally that had happened at the same time,
um,
they invented the hourglass and the hourglass keeps,
you know,
time between one hour and another and then the,
the clock,
which at the beginning it was only in the bell tower,
you know,
chimes the hour for the,
the whole city.
And so it's the hourglass that people would time their,
you know,
their activities with and so forth and professors would time their lectures and
people would,
um,
you know,
agree to meet at certain times.
And just that temporal coordination was happening quite a bit more in Europe
than,
than anywhere else.
And they also turn it into a navigational technique called the dead reckoning,
where you would,
you would look at,
you're not slipping through the water,
and then you'd use the hourglass to measure the time.
And then you would also use that hourglass to record the time record when you
made the measurement.
And so you'd keep track just dead reckoning of how far you're going.
And that's a technique Columbus used and Magellan used and so forth.
So that hourglass we've used and all that stuff and underappreciated under
appreciate it.
Yeah.
And there's some poor guy's job.
It was to flip it every hour.
Exactly on the hour.
If you had,
uh,
a gigantic billboard could put anything on it,
just a,
a message to get out too.
Millions of people are more,
what would you potentially put on that?
Does anything come to mind?
Gigantic billboard.
Well,
um,
the phrasing of all quoted me earlier,
trusted third parties are security holes.
Anybody in the blockchain space?
I would,
I would like to get that in their head.
That that's basically the key to the whole design,
why the whole design is like it is and so forth.
Nivalis do you have any other questions before I wrap up with a few?
No.
I mean I,
I would just really encourage people to go read Nick's blog.
He is a true polymath.
He's written about stuff.
Um,
as he mentioned,
ranging from the hourglasses and clocks,
the industrial revolution to blockchains to law and policy and privacy and
rights and singularity and freedoms.
And,
um,
it,
I,
I just learned something every time I go to his blog is I've probably not
finished about half the pieces on there.
Um,
and they're always a highly inspirational educational.
Yeah.
People often ask me,
listeners,
ask,
uh,
be a question related to the maxim that you hear in Silicon Valley a lot,
which is you're the average of the five people that you associate with most.
What do I do if I don't have access to five people?
I want to be the average of,
and the answer or one of the answers is read,
choose your reading sources very wisely.
And I would agree.
The depth and breadth of what you cover is really,
really stunning.
My smartest,
uh,
teachers,
mentors,
peers these days are all on Twitter and logs and they're,
is,
they're mostly autodidacts.
Like they might have a,
they're self taught,
right?
Fancy word,
but they might have a,
um,
degrees and whatever,
but reality.
But the reality is they're curious people.
And the Internet is the myth of the library of Alexandria writ large.
Like you can find anything and everything.
You can become an expert in anything.
You can talk to anybody.
Um,
so I used to feel guilty about spending so much time on the Internet,
but now I don't,
as long as I'm reading interesting things from the people that I think are
really smart.
What's the downside?
Agreed on Twitter.
Where can people say hello?
What is your Twitter?
My Twitter handle is at Nick Savo for okay.
And that's nic k.
Hmm.
S Z.
Okay.
Yes.
Abo the number four.
Number four.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Well that I think about covers it for a first gathering,
that cousin of all.
And uh,
you can get a 25% discount on novel coin if you go to tim.blog for us to no,
I'm kidding.
Uh,
that is,
hence sizes are going up.
Prices are going up.
Oh wait,
that's not all.
We'll have hopefully more for you guys soon.
This was a real blast.
Thanks so much for the time,
nick.
Thank you.
This is really fun.
And the vol.
Always a pleasure.
Thank you for helping put this together.
Thank you for having us.
It's fantastic and to everybody listening,
we will have show notes,
links to everything we mentioned,
Nick's blog books,
as many resources as we can think of.
Probably cryptocurrency,
one o one a handful of articles we'll recommend in sequence as well in the show
notes.
You can find those at tim.blog/podcast and that will take you to shit on us for
every other episode as well and until next time.
As always,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
I absolutely love audio books and they are one of my favorite ways to pass the
time when I,
I'm on the road all the time.
And audible allows me to consume many more books than I possibly could otherwise
I have to audio books to recommend right off the bat.
The first is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time.
It's the only audiobook I've wanted to listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding by Rolf Hots,
p,
O,
t t,
s which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what
would later become the four hour workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines,
and much more as a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash.
Tim You can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it.
So turn your travel or your commute into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start now and get your free 30 day trial.
This episode is brought to you by fresh books,
man.
Oh Man.
Do a lot of listeners of this podcast and readers in mind love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with the CEO not very long ago.
Why are they so popular?
Well,
they are the number one cloud accounting software designed exclusively for self
employed professionals.
That's many of you and used by more than 10 million people.
You can send invoices,
track your time and get paid very,
very quickly,
which suits the needs of a lot of freelancers.
I left the [inaudible] and beyond.
You can't take pictures of receipts.
You can link your credit card and debit card.
So all the things you buy automatically appear in your fresh books in the right
category,
so on and so forth.
Makes taxes easy,
makes invoices easy,
it makes your life easier.
And also in fact,
I recommend a pdf.
Uh,
they didn't ask me to read this part by the way.
They put together a pdf a while back called breaking the time barrier.
Subtitle,
how to unlock your true earning potential so you can search for breaking the
time barrier.
A lot of people ask me,
how can I get a four hour work week with a service business?
And the story in that Ebook,
it's pdf is the short answer is really,
really good.
So I think you should also check that out.
So breaking the time error,
check it out,
but also why not test out freshbooks?
Claim your 30 day unrestricted free trial@freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and
enter timferriss two rs and two ss in the,
how did you hear about us section?
That sounds like we're going to get very little tracking.
That's a lot of work,
but just go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim and tried out because it is a
very good product and I think you will find it simplifies your life.
Joy.